Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Pulsierende, elektronische Musik *
* Mehrstimmiger Chorgesang *
# S isch äben e Mönsch uf Ärde.
# Chueli, chum!
# Ai wanna bii milking yuu.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
* Tiefe Tubaklänge *
* Mehrstimmige Hackbrettmusik *
* Sanfter Jodelgesang *
* Elektroklänge *
# Und die Engel und Heiligen alle,
sie sollen uns gnädig bewahren.
# Vor Übel, Unglück und Gefahren.
* Jauchzer *
Volksmusik?
Das ist ein breiter Begriff.
Was Volksmusik ist? Äh ...
Was soll ich sagen?
Mir fällt nichts ein.
Ich möchte mir nicht
die Finger verbrennen
und Volksmusik
ganz genau definieren.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Ich habe aufgehört,
mir diese Frage zu stellen.
Ich suchte früher
immer nach Antworten,
aber ich glaube,
es ist eine Worthülse.
Es ist ein Konstrukt,
worunter sich alle
irgendetwas vorstellen.
Volksmusik ist Musik des Volks.
Die wandelt sich,
wie das Volk sich wandelt.
Für mich ist Volksmusik Heimat.
Volksmusik ist etwas,
das überlebt und Tradition hat.
Nicht alles mit Jauchzern
ist Volksmusik.
Es ist auf jeden Fall
ein tolles Hobby.
Es ist eine Lebensweise, es geht
urchig und lustig zu und her.
Wenn es natürlich und mit Freude
zelebriert wird.
Es ist ein breites Genre
mit vielen Facetten.
Für mich ist Volksmusik
etwas Liebliches.
Es ist etwas Wohltuendes.
Darum darf es nicht zu schräg sein,
sonst ist es nicht mehr wohltuend.
Musik, die verbindet,
Musik auf einer Herzfrequenz,
die sehr viele Menschen anspricht,
die sich vielleicht rein sprachlich
nicht verstehen würden.
Es gibt keine Grenzen.
Volksmusik ist Herzmusik.
Ich legte mir mal eine Definition
für mich selber zurecht.
Volksmusik ist für mich kein Jazz,
keine Popmusik, keine Schlagermusik
und keine klassische Musik.
Und das sind die Musikrichtungen,
die man gut identifizieren kann.
Wenn es nichts davon ist,
könnte es
in Richtung Volksmusik gehen.
Es ist eine billige Definition,
aber es ist eine von Tausenden.
Wir hören Ueli Mooser.
- Ländlerkapelle Ueli Mooser.
Ueli Mooser.
Komponist, Arrangeur, Musiker
und Musiklehrer: Ueli Mooser.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
(Wyss) Ueli Mooser - Legende.
Wirklich.
Seit ich mich für Volkmusik
interessiere, tauchte er immer auf.
Als ich als Kind fernsah, tauchte er
in fast jeder Sendung auf -
mal am Bass, mal an der Klarinette,
mal an der Gitarre.
* Gemächliche Musik *
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
* Rasante Ländlermusik *
(Mooser) Nach und nach legte ich mir
eine Instrumentensammlung an.
Und auf jedem Instrument
wollte ich so viel lernen,
damit es für öffentliche Auftritte
brauchbar war.
Damit die Kollegen
nicht wütend wurden.
Bei einigen Instrumenten schaffte
ich es, andere liess ich dann sein.
* Langsame, tiefe Klänge *
Also, ein B-Dur-Akkord.
Der kommt immer am Anfang.
Der blöde Griff ist Es.
Der ist sehr schwierig.
Man muss immer hin und zurück
und hin und zurück und hin.
Jetzt kommt noch der dritte,
den man braucht: F7.
Wenn man diese drei Griffe hat
und sie auf verschiedenen Tonarten
spielen kann,
kann man praktisch
jedes Ländlermusikstück begleiten.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Ich betrachte mich
als professionellen Musiker.
Darum muss ich an mich selber
gewisse Ansprüche stellen.
Klarinette.
Das ist das tägliche Brot.
Das bedeutet: Etüden spielen.
Auf Youtube kann man schauen,
wie andere das gut machen.
Es geht schnell
und sieht alles so einfach aus,
aber wenn man selber den Schnabel
mit dem Blatt im Mund hat,
ist alles unglaublich schwierig.
Ich kann auch schlecht und hässlich
spielen, wenn es sein muss.
Dann klingt es vielleicht urchig,
nach Miststock oder Gülle.
Das meine ich
überhaupt nicht negativ.
Urchige Musik,
die mit Herz gespielt wird,
ist auch schöne Musik.
Nicht nur die,
die man am Konservatorium lernt.
Ich erinnere mich an eine Szene
von Dani Häusler,
einem sehr guten Klarinettisten:
Er erzählte, er habe
an der Steiner Chilbi gespielt.
Dann kam einer und meinte:
"Du spielst schön Klarinette,
wunderbar!"
Dann meinte Dani Häusler,
das müsse er schon,
er habe am Konservatorium
Klarinette studiert und sei Profi.
Da meinte der andere,
dann sei es ja einfach.
Was mir an der Volksmusikszene
gefällt, ist,
dass es vorwiegend Laienmusik ist.
Sie wird v.a.
von Leuten praktiziert,
die einen anderen Beruf haben.
Diese Kombination
finde ich sehr schön,
denn es ist etwas Nerdiges.
Also diejenigen, die sich
wirklich damit auseinandersetzen,
machen das zwar als Hobby,
aber sehr spezifisch und gezielt.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
(Mooser) Die Einfachheit
der Volksmusik faszinierte mich.
Man konnte ohne Weiteres
alles nachvollziehen.
Sie ist nicht abhängig vom Sound,
wie Popmusik es ist.
Sie ist formal, einfach, harmonisch.
Nur in der Melodik
gibt es höhere Ansprüche.
Ich spreche jetzt
speziell von Ländlermusik,
und die erfordert
eine gewisse Virtuosität.
Es ist interessant:
Auch wenn man nicht viel
von Musik versteht,
hört man sofort,
ob es afrikanische
oder chinesische Volksmusik ist.
Das hört man.
Das hat wohl mit unserer Landschaft
zu tun, und das fasziniert mich.
Z.B. der Appenzeller Naturjutz.
* Wehmütiger Jodelgesang *
Mit diesen wehmütigen,
schönen Melodien,
die eigentlich
unsere Landschaft beschreiben.
Es gibt mir eine innerliche Kraft.
Ich kann beim Musikmachen auftanken.
Wenn man merkt,
dass die Leute Freude haben,
es sie ergreift und man mit Musik
etwas erwecken kann,
ist das das Schönste.
Wenn man unterwegs ist und in einem
Restaurant, z.B. in den Bergen,
diese Musik hört und erleben kann,
finde ich das sehr faszinieren.
Man fährt eine Stunde aus Zürich
und ist in einer Region,
in der eine gewisse Volksmusik
gespielt wird.
Fährt man eine Stunde weiter,
klingt die Musik ganz anders.
Es ist beeindruckend,
dass in diesem kleinen Land
die Musik überall anders klingt.
* Lebhafte Schwyzerörgelimusik *
(Mooser) Der Sound
des Schwyzerörgelis ist einzigartig,
da das Instrument
in der Schweiz gebaut wurde.
Daran hört man es.
Wie mir Dieter Ringli erklärte,
Fachmann für Volksmusik
in der Schweiz,
ist seltsamerweise
auch die Besetzung einmalig,
also Klarinette, Akkordeon,
Klavier und Kontrabass.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Das ist irgendwie typisch.
In allen Folkloren der Welt,
die ich bis jetzt gehört habe,
habe ich diese Besetzung
noch nie gefunden.
(Ringli) Typisch für die Schweiz
ist diese rhythmische Präzision.
Das findet man im Alpenraum
in dieser Form sonst nicht.
In Österreich und Bayern sind die
Tempi eher schleppend, verzögernd,
und die Schweiz ist fadengerade.
Zürich hat für die Ländlermusik
eine zentrale Bedeutung.
Das ist eine relativ neue Geschichte
von Anfang des 20. Jh.,
als die Schwyzerörgeli aufkamen.
Im 19. Jh. gab es viele Tanzkapellen
mit Streichern und Bläsern.
Dann kam das Örgeli,
was total Sinn ergibt.
Mit zwei Bläsern und zwei Streichern
kann man die durch eine Handorgel
fast ersetzen.
Als das Örgeli langsam aufkam,
wurden die Bläser wegrationalisiert.
Es war günstiger, zu dritt
zu spielen, und man verdiente mehr.
Es ist auch einfacher,
mit einem oder zwei Akkordeons
den Groove zu erzeugen.
Wieso es in der Schweiz so war
und in anderen Ländern nicht,
weiss ich nicht.
Die Ländlermusik entstand nicht
in Zürich, überhaupt nicht.
Sie ist
eine Innerschweizer Angelegenheit.
Dann kam sie in die Stadt,
wie ein Ethnoboom.
Zürich ist ein gutes Beispiel,
um zu zeigen,
dass es oft
einen urbanen Raum braucht,
um ein Phänomen populär zu machen.
Die Ländlermusik
war in den 1920er- und 1930er-Jahren
der Party-Ska -
mit Upbeat-Tempo und Offbeat-betont.
Sie war ein ziemlicher Erfolg.
Die katholische Innerschweizer
Fest- und Trinkfreudigkeit
machte wahnsinnig Eindruck.
Es gibt einige wichtige Namen.
Die zwei Antipoden
und wichtigen Männer -
es waren natürlich nur Männer -
waren Stocker Sepp
und Kasi Geisser.
Stocker Sepp ...
- ... beherrschte die Ländlerszene
von Zürich
fast mit mafiaähnlichen Methoden.
Er war v.a. der Organisationsking.
Er baute fast
ein Ländlerimperium auf.
Er spielte selber Klarinette.
Ordentlich,
aber nie so gut wie Kasi Geisser.
Der war das Gegenteil -
in dem Sinne, dass er
ein Klarinetten- und Musikgenie war,
aber sein Leben
null auf die Reihe kriegte.
Er führte beinahe
ein Rockstar-Leben.
Das war so das Ländlerleben
in den 20er- und 30er-Jahren.
Ein Höhepunkt für die Ländlermusik
war dann die Landesausstellung,
die Landi 39, von 1939.
# Das hänt mir schön und klar,
die Berge wiss vo Schnee.
# Lueg, d'Sunne schiint,
das isch e Pracht,
# mir alli sind so froh.
(Ringli)
Die Landi 39 ist extrem wichtig,
denn dort steigt die Volksmusik
quasi in den sozialen Schichten auf.
Vorher war es eher
Rotlichtmilieu-Unterhaltung
für die Unter- und Mittelschicht.
Im Zweiten Weltkrieg wurde sie Teil
der Geistigen Landesverteidigung.
Die Landi fiel in eine Zeit,
in der die grösste Gefahr herrschte
seit Beginn der Hunderte Jahre alten
Eidgenossenschaft.
(Originalton) Am 30. Juli,
1., 5. und 6. August
wurden im Rahmen der Landi
auf der Wollishofer Allmend
bei Zürich
grosse Wehrvorführungen
durchgeführt.
Die Geistige Landesverteidigung
wurde ja staatlich aufgezogen,
um sich von den umliegenden
faschistischen Staaten abzugrenzen,
also von Nazi-Deutschland,
Österreich,
das ans Reich angeschlossen wurde,
und Italien unter Mussolini,
und um unser Schweizerisches
zu betonen.
# Die Lüt, wo sind a d'Landi cho.
(Originalton) Es gab
nicht nur Lieder über die Landi,
an der Landi
wurde auch wacker musiziert.
Einer, der an der Landi spielte,
war Stocker Sepp.
Seine Frau, Rosa Stocker,
kramt in Erinnerungen.
Am 6. wurde die Landi eröffnet.
Und am 7. spielte Stocker
zum ersten Mal dort draussen.
Das war dann manchmal
ein Riesengaudi und ein Zeug.
Ein Marschlied
hiess "Im Landhaus isch Sänneball!",
und dieses Landhaus
war im Landi-Dorf.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
(Brülisauer) Die Ländlermusik wurde
quasi zur Nationalmusik stilisiert -
zusammen mit anderen Elementen
der musikalischen Volkskultur
wie Jodeln, Alphornblasen
oder auch Fahnenschwingen.
Also so ganz typische Dinge,
die quasi als urschweizerisch
betrachtet werden.
Das wurde auch gezielt genutzt,
um das Gefühl zu vermitteln,
dass wir Schweizer sind
und nicht die anderen.
Es wurde ein Stück weit
auch dafür missbraucht.
# Ich kenn es Dörfli am Zürisee ...
(Ringli) Dass die Ländlermusik
in der Kriegszeit
zum Nationalgeist wurde,
hatte später Nachteile.
1945 gingen die Grenzen wieder auf
und der Wirtschaftsboom kam.
Dann kamen die spannenden Dinge
zuerst aus Paris, London
und dann aus New York, den USA.
Da kamen die spannenden Dinge her,
und darauf wurde nicht reagiert.
* Lebhafter Jodelgesang *
Bei mir
fing das mit meinem Vater an.
In dieser Familie
hatte man früher gesungen.
Damals hatte man
noch keine Instrumente.
Mein Vater war einer der Familie,
die ein Instrument lernen durften.
Bei uns ging es gleich weiter.
Dahinter steckte aber nie ein Zwang.
Darum ist es umso schöner,
wenn etwas entstehen kann,
das mittlerweile
auch erfolgreich ist.
Das darf ich so sagen.
Wenn man die Volksmusik
in der Familie zusammennimmt,
sind es über 50 Jahre.
Das macht einen auch stolz.
Es ist ein grosser gemeinsamer
Nenner in unserer Familie.
Volksmusik lebt von der Weitergabe.
Sie wurde
in der Familie weitergegeben -
von Grossvätern an Väter, an Kinder.
Das war früher der einzige Weg,
die Musik weiterzugeben.
Das hat die Musik zu dem gemacht,
was sie heute ist.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Zu meinen Instrumenten
kam ich durch die Familie.
In unserer Familie
wurde immer gesungen und musiziert,
v.a. Papa übte viel
und machte viel Musik.
Zu Hause stand immer eine Handorgel,
ein Schwyzerörgeli
oder eine Bassgeige herum.
Meine Onkel und deren Cousins
waren schon
eine bekannte Ländlerformation.
Auch meine Eltern waren musikalisch.
Es wurde mir in die Wiege gelegt.
Wurde Ihnen das musikalische Talent
in die Wiege gelegt? - Nein.
Es fiel oft der Satz:
"Es wurde dir in die Wiege gelegt."
Das Musikmachen.
Das Gehör wurde mir sicher
ein Stück weit in die Wiege gelegt,
aber das Üben selber,
das Beherrschen eines Instruments,
ist mit Selbstdisziplin
und Ehrgeiz verbunden.
Das Musikmachen
und das Arbeiten auf der Alp
oder auf dem Betrieb
verbindet die Familie.
Man hat etwas zu tun
und arbeitet auf etwas hin.
Das gibt einem Motivation.
Immer, wenn wir zusammenkommen,
haben wir ein Ziel
oder eine Arbeit vor uns,
die wir miteinander erledigen.
Das gibt einen schönen Zusammenhalt
und ist etwas sehr Schönes.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
(Wyss) Cécile Schmidig
kommt auch aus einer Familie,
in der Volksmusik
so richtig gelebt wird.
Es sind viele bekannte Namen
der Szene.
Es ist sehr schön zu sehen,
dass es weitergeht,
dass aus einer Familie
die nächste Generation hervorgeht,
die diese Musik so weiterlebt,
wie man sie lebte,
aber auch genug offen ist,
um sie zu verändern.
* Mehrstimmiger Gesang *
Es fing eigentlich
mit meinen Grosseltern an.
Sie waren beide sehr musikalisch.
Die Grossmutter komponierte Lieder.
# Einisch ufe Stoos,
fahrsch mit de Stoos-Bahn us.
Der Grossvater
spielte auch Handorgel.
Er machte sehr viele Kompositionen.
Er komponierte rund 80-100 Tänze.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Die Schmidig-Tänze
haben einen grossen Namen
und sind
in der ganzen Volksmusik verwurzelt.
Von einem grossen Teil
der Formationen
werden diese Tänze auch gespielt.
Mein Stil ist der Illgauer-Stil
oder Innerschweizer Stil,
wie wir ihn nennen.
Man möchte sofort mitschunkeln
oder mittanzen.
Es lupft einen einfach.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
(Heinzer) Die Musik ist sehr rund.
Man kann sie auf beide Seiten
spielen, auch konzertant.
Das hat dann einen anderen Effekt.
Auf der Tanzfläche
sind es aber die idealen Tänze.
Ich habe
schon viele Platten digitalisiert
und bin immer wieder überrascht,
wenn ich eine finde,
bei der ich das Cover
und das, was drauf ist, nicht kenne.
Das ist eine aus dem obersten Regal,
in die ich mal reinhörte.
Die habe ich angeschrieben:
"Gefällige VoU-Musik".
Das bedeutet Volksunterhaltungsmusik
mit Sheng -
das ist der Vorläufer
der Mundharmonika.
Ein altes Blasinstrument.
Ich habe schon lange
nicht mehr reingehört.
* Fernöstlich angehauchte Klänge *
Das klingt noch ziemlich westlich.
Sie ist auf Chinesisch oder so
angeschrieben.
Operettenfolklore.
* Langsame,
fernöstlich angehauchte Klänge *
Ja ...
Klingt schon wie eine Mundharmonika.
Diese Musik
könnte man in einem China-Restaurant
im Hintergrund hören.
Ich konnte diese Plattensammlung
vom Studio Zürich übernehmen.
Ich fragte mich, wem die Sammlung
am meisten etwas bringt.
So kam ich
auf die Musikhochschule Luzern.
Vielleicht haben die Studierenden
ein Interesse daran,
wie Ländlermusik
früher einmal klang.
Wir sind hier im Hörraum
der Musikhochschule Luzern.
Ich würde gerne
ein paar Platten abspielen,
auf die ich besonderen Wert lege,
da sie einen Teil meiner Entwicklung
in der Ländlermusik darstellen.
Ueli Mooser ist kein Urvolksmusiker,
sondern wie ein Quereinsteiger.
Vielleicht hinterfragte er deshalb
schon immer Dinge,
die einfach so waren.
Das faszinierte mich immer.
Das ist eine Art Kuckucksei.
So könnte man das nennen.
Die Ländlerkapelle Zoge-n-am Boge
war früher führend und sehr bekannt
für wirklich urchige
und schöne Bündner Musik.
Josias Jenny
war für mich ein Riesenvorbild.
Er ist derjenige,
der bei mir die
Freude am Schwyzerörgeli auslöste.
Ich stiess auf die Platte
vom Trio Zoge-n-am Boge.
Und da war das Feuer dann entfacht.
Zuerst traute ich mich nicht,
da ich das Gefühl hatte,
zu wenig zu können,
um mit diesen Koryphäen zu spielen,
aber als ich
den Offizier abverdiente,
dachte ich, mit dieser Uniform
könne ich es mir erlauben.
Sie hatten ein schönes Repertoire,
und ich hatte das Gefühl,
das müsse man mal wieder
auf Platte aufnehmen.
Ich hatte die Idee,
noch ein Klavier
zur Originalbesetzung hinzuzunehmen.
Halszither, Posaune und Kornett
waren noch dabei.
Meine Kollegen von Zoge-n-am Boge
winkten erst einmal ab.
Die Fans seien damit nicht zufrieden
und v.a. das Klavier
habe keinen Platz
in der sog. urchigen Bündner Musik.
Früher gab es immer ein Theater
mit der Bündner Musik.
"Spinnst du?"
"Dieses verdammte Gedudel!"
Die Bündner fanden, das Klavier
gehöre nicht in die Volksmusik.
Damals
gab es noch diese Grabenkämpfe.
Das war so.
Jesses Maria ...
Ich weiss noch, dass wir manchmal
2'000, 3'000 Briefe erhielten.
Hier hört man das Klavier heraus,
das eben nicht
in diesen Stil gehört.
Dann meinten sie,
sie würden das gerne aufnehmen,
aber auf keinen Fall
unter dem Namen Zoge-n-am Boge -
um die Fans nicht zu verärgern.
"Nennen wir es einfach
Ländlerkapelle Ueli Mooser,
und wir spielen mit."
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Es ist sicher fetzig und urchig,
aber wenn ich dem Klavier
und dem Kontrabass zuhöre,
zieht es mir fast
die Zehennägel ein.
Das würde man heute nie so machen.
Aber es lebt und es fetzt.
Das war damals die Hauptsache.
Es war für mich
ein persönlicher Erfolg.
Ich war damals ja ein Nobody.
Die erfahrenen Kollegen
aus der Ländlermusik,
die alle
schon einen Riesennamen hatten -
Josias Jenny, Thomas Marthaler
usw. -, hörten auf mich.
"Wundertüte -
Rocktümlicher Volk'n'Roll".
Ein Stück,
das ich vorher komponiert hatte
für die Engadiner Ländlerfründä
und das heute noch
ein sog. Ländlerhit ist:
"Malojawind",
ein Cross-over aus dem Jahr 1984.
Da kommt jetzt Rhythmus hinzu.
* Rasante, rhythmische Ländlermusik *
Es ist Musik
zwischen Stuhl und Bank.
Ein Rockfreund
hat keine Freude daran,
ein Ländlerfreund auch nicht.
Die Wichtigsten hatten Freude -
das waren wir.
* Rasante, rhythmische Ländlermusik *
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Das ist auch eine Eigenheit
der Schweizer Volksmusik:
Es gibt eine strikte Trennung
zwischen instrumentaler
und vokaler Volksmusik.
(Mooser) Gesang hat für mich
insofern einen Stellenwert,
dass ich ihn zur Kenntnis nehme.
Ich bin ein Instrumentalist.
Ich schliesse mich Wysel Gyr an:
Vokale Platten
taxierte er in der Plattensammlung
z.B. mit "Leider mit Gesang".
Und wenn ihm der Gesang
sehr gut gefiel,
schrieb er
"Leider mit Gesang, trotzdem gut".
Dem kann ich mich anschliessen.
Wenn es mir gut geht,
kann ich singen,
aber auch, wenn nicht.
In mir herrscht dann ein eigen-
artiges, fast mystisches Gefühl.
Dann überkommt es selbst mich.
Alle, die das einmal erlebt haben,
die im Appenzell das Glück hatten,
zu sehen,
wie Leute
einfach zu singen beginnen -
das geht nicht spurlos
an einem vorbei.
# S isch äben e Mönsch uf Ärde,
woni möcht bi n'ihm si.
Für mich war das Singen
immer auch viel Verarbeitung.
Schon mein ganzes Leben lang.
Gesang in der Volksmusik
ist eine Eigenheit in der Schweiz.
Es gibt die instrumentale Volksmusik
und die mit Gesang.
Es ist schade,
dass das nicht mehr zusammen ist.
Es ist sehr schön,
dass so viele Leute es bewahren,
wie der Jodlerverband
das vor über 100 Jahren festlegte.
Für mich ist aber auch wichtig,
dass es etwas daneben gibt,
ohne da jemandem zu nahe zu treten.
Ich muss ein wenig ausschweifen,
um auf meine Kosten zu kommen.
Beim Jodeln fasziniert mich,
dass es eine Technik ist,
die man ohne Worte singen kann.
* Gefühlvoller Jodelgesang *
Ich durfte ja schon
auf der ganzen Welt spielen.
Ich kann die Naturjutzer singen
und werde verstanden.
Jodeln ist wie Alpkäse: Jede Alp
und jede Region sind anders.
Alle sind einzigartig
und wunderschön.
Das widerspiegelt sich
in der Musik und im Gesang.
* Gefühlvoller Jodelgesang *
Als Jodlerin finde ich,
dass Jodeln und Singen
unbedingt in die Volksmusik gehören
und ein wichtiger Teil davon sind.
Mein Götti,
der in einer Ostschweizer Formation
Handorgel spielte, sagte immer,
eine richtige Kapelle singe auch.
Könnte ich nicht singen,
wäre ich in der Psychiatrie.
Es tut einfach gut.
Ein Tag ohne singen, also jodeln,
ist kein richtiger Tag.
Als kleines Kind erzählte ich allen,
ich würde Jodlerin werden.
Und das zog sich
durch mein ganzes Leben.
* Gefühlvoller Jodelgesang *
* Beschwingter Jodelgesang *
Nadja Räss
ist eine hervorragende Jodlerin.
Und sie macht vieles
für die Vermittlung des Jodels.
Sie kam aus der Tradition.
Dann wollte sie die Regeln sprengen
und suchte neue Wege.
* Lebhafter,
rhythmischer Jodelgesang *
Und inzwischen
leitet sie die Volksmusikabteilung
an der Hochschule Luzern
und leistet eine grandiose Arbeit,
damit man Volksmusik auch an einer
Schule professionell erlernen kann.
Es ist ganz toll,
was sie alles schon gemacht hat
für unsere Kultur und das Jodeln.
Sie ist höchst professionell.
Was sie anpackt, klappt auch.
Das Faszinierende
ist aber immer ihre Stimme.
Sie hat es einfach noch mehr drauf
als viele andere,
die auch sehr gut sind.
Ich hatte den grossen Wunsch,
Musik zum Beruf zu machen.
Leider
hatte ich die Chance noch nicht.
Ich bin jetzt auch zu alt dafür.
Ich studierte dann
klassischen Gesang.
Aber schon während des Studiums
sagte ich immer,
irgendwann würde man in der Schweiz
Volksmusik studieren können.
Das kann man jetzt.
Spürst du die Kraft im Boden?
Die nehmen wir mit
und gehen gleich ins Brustregister.
(Lang gezogen) # Ne-e-e.
Meine Rolle
an der Hochschule Luzern Musik
ist die Verantwortung
im Fachbereich Volksmusik.
Das beinhaltet
die Gestaltung des Programms,
die Einladung von Gastdozenten,
Ansprechperson
für die Studierenden zu sein
und dafür zu sorgen, dass ab und zu
eine Stubete stattfindet,
aber auch die Weiterentwicklung
des Studienbereichs.
Dazu gehörte in den letzten Jahren
die Entwicklung eines Bachelors
im Bereich Volksmusik.
Und aktuell denken wir
über einen Master Volksmusik nach.
# Du hesch nie gseid,
du hegsch mi gäre.
# Und hesch mir doch so vil gäh.
# Hesch mir mengisch
mit dim Lache ...
Ich darf gerade mit
Dayana Pfammatter Gurten arbeiten.
Dayana ist die erste Jodelstudentin
und wird mich schon bald verlassen.
Vor uns liegt das letzte Semester.
Wir arbeiten gerade an einem Lied
von Willi Valotti,
"Hesch nie gseid",
das er mir widmete.
Es ist ein wunderbares Lied,
das eine Freundschaft beschreibt.
Er schrieb den Jodel
nicht ganz so einfach.
Es kommen andere Sprünge vor
als bei einem normalen,
traditionelleren Jodellied.
Das ist die grosse Herausforderung.
Darum probieren wir gerade aus,
wie wir es einfacher machen können.
Es soll ganz einfach klingen,
aber richtig.
Dass Volksmusik
an einer Hochschule gelehrt wird,
hat zur Folge,
dass sich einzelne Personen
sehr intensiv
und auf eine andere Art
mit dieser Musik auseinandersetzen.
Es ist eine Chance, wie sich
die Musik weiterentwickeln könnte.
Ich sehe eine gewisse Gefahr darin,
dass der Kunstanteil überhandnimmt.
Luzern hat im Moment die Tendenz,
sich der Klassik anzunähern und
mehr Komplexität hineinzubringen.
Wenn man in Punk
mehr Komplexität bringt,
ist es irgendwann nicht mehr lustig.
Man lernt dort sicher viel.
Ich finde es aber wichtig,
dass sie auf dem Boden bleiben -
mit der Tradition und dem Singen.
Und dass man die Eigenarten
der Schweiz gut pflegt.
Die Gefahr, dass es
durch die Hochschule etwas verliert,
sehe ich überhaupt nicht.
Es gibt in der Schweiz
eine so grosse Laienbewegung.
An der Hochschule setzt man sich
weitgehend mit Musik auseinander.
Man stellt natürlich ganz bewusst
alles infrage,
analysiert,
was toll ist und was nicht,
und sucht sich dann
mit einem grossen Werkzeugkasten
den eigenen Weg.
Die gehen dann raus
und unterrichten an Musikschulen,
Primarschulen,
Oberstufen und Gymnasien.
Sie kamen mit Volksmusik
in Berührung
und dann unterrichten sie Kinder,
die sonst vielleicht nicht
damit in Berührung kämen.
So erreichen wir
viele Leute ganz anders
und ausserhalb unserer Szene.
Da sehe ich eine grosse Chance.
Wir haben eine Fachdidaktiklektion.
D.h., ich schaue Dayana zu,
wie sie Madeleine unterrichtet
und gebe ihr dann ein Feedback.
Wir lernen hier singen,
aber auch lehren.
Ein Masterstudium
mit Hauptfach Jodeln dient dazu,
nicht nur traditionellen Dingen
nachzugehen,
sondern auch experimentierfreudig
zu sein
und sich auf Dinge einzulassen.
Das eröffnet neue Perspektiven.
Das gehört dazu.
* Beschwingter Jodelgesang *
Ich stehe dem Experimentieren
nicht negativ gegenüber.
Ich mochte es manchmal auch,
neuere Dinge zu singen.
Für mich waren sie aber trotz allem
immer noch traditionell.
Dazu kann ich gut stehen.
Für mich ist die Grenze erreicht,
wenn es zu schräg wird.
Dann ist es mir nicht mehr wohl.
* Jodelgesang mit Elektromusik *
Christine Lauterburg
hat viel experimentiert.
Davon distanziere ich mich ziemlich.
Sie ist eine grossartige Künstlerin.
Ihr Erfolg und Bekanntheitsgrad
sagen eigentlich alles.
Ich will mich nicht dazu äussern.
Es ist einfach nicht meine Art.
Ich finde es gut, dass man Dinge
ausprobiert und die Vielfalt zeigt.
Das macht die Szene farbenreich.
Und für das Publikum
ist es spannend,
nicht immer das Gleiche zu sehen.
- Genau.
Ich wollte einfach etwas machen,
das mit mir selber zu tun hat,
bei dem ich mich
nicht verstellen muss.
Vorher war ich noch Schauspielerin.
Ich hatte die Nase voll vom Theater.
Ich wollte etwas Schönes machen,
für mich allein.
Und dann ...
Ich hörte Jodeln schon früher.
Ich war auf einer Bergtour
und hörte jemanden jodeln,
ohne ihn zu sehen.
Da erinnerte ich mich wieder
an alles.
* Lang gezogener Ton *
Meine Eltern jodelten nicht.
Wir machten schon Musik,
aber es war eher Bach und Vivaldi.
Ich bin immer noch Fan
von Jakob Ummel und Vreni Kneubühl.
# Wie schön isches z'wandere
de Bärge zue.
# Mit Stäcke und Rucksack
und gnaglete Schueh.
Wie die beiden sangen -
das sind meine Vorbilder.
Was meinen Gesang betrifft,
ist mein Vorbild Miles Davis.
Er produzierte auch so lange,
kunstvolle Töne.
Als ich anfing,
machte ich es einfach auf meine Art.
Ich kannte es auch nicht so gut.
Ich wusste auch nicht,
wie viel man nicht darf.
Und dass es viele Einschränkungen
vom Jodlerverband gibt.
Ich machte einfach frisch drauflos,
wie es mir gefiel.
Aus Naivität - nennen wir es so.
Und Spielfreude.
Wir nannten das damals Dancefloor -
mit synthetischen Beats und Bässen,
die den Jodel unterlegten.
Der Eidgenössische Jodlerverband
schimpfte da schon.
* Elektronische Musik mit Jodel *
Eigentlich
gefällt mir Techno überhaupt nicht,
wegen des einfachen Schlagzeugbeats.
Vier Viertel, gerade durch -
eine ziemlich simple Geschichte.
Ich fand es aber witzig,
dass sie
etwas Schweizerdeutsches einbauten.
Das sind halt einfach Rhythmen,
zu denen ich jodeln konnte.
Im freien Fall.
Meistens
lag es auch an den Kleidern.
Ich bin da nicht so brav
mit der Tracht.
Ich experimentierte da
natürlich auch ein wenig.
Zu gewissen Menschen
passt das komplett Traditionelle.
Mir gefällt beides, es muss einfach
für die stimmen, die es machen.
* Ruhiger Jodelgesang *
# ... u fiischter schiint in d'Wält.
Ich finde,
eigentlich ist alles erlaubt.
* Rasanter Jodelgesang *
Das Bewerten
finde ich gar nicht gut.
Das Jodlerfest ist eigentlich
kein Fest, sondern ein Wettkampf.
* Musik
von "Spiel mir das Lied vom Tod" *
* Ruhiger Jodelgesang *
* Sanfter Jodelgesang *
Die Regeln sind dann wichtig,
wenn wir uns messen wollen.
Das ist auch beim Sport so.
Bei den Naturjutzen
gibt es wenige Regeln.
Da muss man den ersten Ton angeben
und kann den Jutz nehmen,
wie man es gewohnt ist.
Bei den Jodelliedern mit Text
und den Jutzen
ist einfach eine
gewisse Vokalisation vorgegeben.
Regeln sind wichtig,
damit alle einigermassen
gleich behandelt werden.
Man muss z.B.
in einer Tracht auftreten.
Das wurde gleichzeitig gross.
Die Trachtenbewegung und
der Jodlerverband laufen parallel.
Das ist bis heute ziemlich strikt.
Ich glaube, das hält viele davon ab,
mitzumachen.
Ich komme aus Herzogenbuchsee
und mache Trachtenstoffe
für die ganze Schweiz.
Von den Strümpfen bis zur Haube
wird alles bei mir gemacht.
(Ringli)
Für Männer ist es einfacher,
aber eine Frauentracht
kostet 10'000 Fr.
Da wird sich aber
wohl vieles ändern,
da man Trachten
so nicht mehr machen kann.
Diese Stoffe gibt es nicht mehr
und die Schneiderinnen sterben aus.
Es braucht aber immer lange,
bis sich so etwas verändert.
Die Reglementierung
hat damit zu tun,
dass es immer Wettbewerbe sind.
Will man etwas bewerten,
braucht es Kriterien.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Interessanterweise
machte der Jodlerverband
vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
eine Umfrage unter den Mitgliedern.
Er wollte die Reglementierung
aufheben
und in Richtung Coaching gehen -
wie bei der Ländlermusik.
Eine grosse Mehrheit der Mitglieder
meinte dann,
die Bewertung
dürfe nicht abgeschafft werden.
Diese Motivation
sei für sie ganz wichtig.
Aber der Nachteil ist natürlich,
dass alles,
was nicht der Reglementierung
entspricht, schlechter abschneidet.
Das verhindert Innovation.
Am Nordostschweizer Jodlerfest
in Herisau
hielt ich am Freitagabend
einen Terzett-Vortrag.
Ich stand hin und erzählte
in der Kirche einen Witz.
Die Leute lachten,
dann sangen wir.
Und am Samstagabend
disqualifizierten sie uns.
Ich erhielt einen Anruf
vom Jodlerverband,
was mir eigentlich einfalle,
sie würden mich rauswerfen.
So etwas gehe doch nicht.
Wenn ich gegen die Regeln verstosse,
müssten sie das
eigentlich sofort sagen:
"Schönen Tag, Sie dürfen gehen."
Dann meinte der Juryleiter,
sie hätten die Regeln nicht gekannt.
# Wii und Bier und Schnapskaffee ...
Es ist alles so angespannt:
"Das steht so, das wird so gemacht."
Meiner Meinung nach
fehlen Humor und Offenheit.
Es dürfte lockerer sein.
Bei vielen Chören sieht man die
Freude nicht mehr, nur noch Stress.
Den musst du nicht draufnehmen,
der passt nicht rein.
(Niederberger) Wir im Jodlerverband
veranstalten alle vier Jahre
ein eidgenössisches Fest.
Dazwischen
gibt es sieben Unterverbandsfeste.
Das gibt eine Klammer
an sozialem Zusammenhalt.
Man misst sich nicht nur,
sondern kommt auch zusammen,
tauscht sich aus und feiert,
damit man gestärkt ist
für den Alltag.
Das ist eine sehr wichtige,
soziale Klammer,
die unser Verband leistet.
* Sanfter Jodelgesang *
Jodeln ist nicht nur
eine Freizeitbeschäftigung.
Wenn man einmal traurig ist,
kann man es einfach rauslassen.
Man spürt die Emotionen genau.
Wenn es einem vielleicht
nicht so gut geht, spürt man es.
Man merkt, dass Jodeln guttun kann.
Jenny Emmenegger gewann
den Folklorenachwuchs-Wettbewerb.
Das ist ein wichtiger Wettbewerb
für junge Volksmusiker/-innen.
Ich sah ihren Auftritt.
Sie stand mit einer solchen
Selbstverständlichkeit auf der Bühne
und konnte so
auch die Jury überzeugen.
Das faszinierte mich sehr.
* Applaus *
Wir gehen ans
Eidgenössische Jodlerfest in Zug.
Ich gehe mit dem Jodlerklub Heimelig
aus Buochs.
Wir freuen uns sehr,
dort jodeln zu dürfen.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Ich muss dich noch frisieren.
Dein Pfeil ist schräg.
Ich weiss,
ich war schon den ganzen Tag ...
Geht's gut? - Ja, und dir?
- Die Stimme? - Top.
Jetzt hält's. Danke.
* Verschiedene Aufwärmübungen *
Schön halten.
Das Einsingen klappte sehr gut.
Wir freuen uns auf den Auftritt
und sind gespannt.
Vom Zentralschweizer Jodlerverband
hören wir als Nächstes
den Jodelklub Heimelig aus Buochs.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Es war einfach herrlich.
Es lief wirklich so,
wie wir es wollten.
Die Freude war da.
Es ist schön. Ich freute mich,
auf der Bühne zu sein und zu jodeln.
Was jetzt noch passiert:
Wir gehen jetzt nach vorne
zu "Potzmusig".
Wir machen uns also bereit
für heute Abend,
um fürs Fernsehen zu jodeln.
Ich freue mich sehr.
Es ist mein erster Fernsehauftritt.
Es war immer mein Traum,
bei "Potzmusig" mitmachen zu dürfen.
Es ist ein schönes Gefühl,
diesen Traum erfüllen zu können.
Herzlich willkommen zu "Potzmusig",
live aus Zug.
Hier ist Nicolas Senn.
Grüezi miteinander. Guten Abend.
Jenny,
wir können los Richtung Bühne.
* Applaus *
* Sanfter Jodelgesang *
Wie ich meinen ersten TV-Auftritt
erlebt habe?
Es war einfach ein schönes Gefühl.
Einfach dort zu jodeln
und es geniessen zu können.
Es lief einfach so, wie gewollt.
Es machte einfach Spass.
Wie kamst du eigentlich zum Jodeln?
Das ist eigentlich
eine ganz lustige Geschichte.
Ähm ...
Mein Grossvater hatte mal Geburtstag
und veranstaltete ein Fest.
Da kamen seine Cousins und jodelten.
Ich dachte mir,
ich könne einfach mal mitmachen.
Und das klappte auf Anhieb?
- Ja.
Es braucht das Talent,
singen zu können.
Es braucht eine gute Stimme
und Musikgehör.
Danach kann man vieles lernen.
Es ist nicht nur Talent,
es ist dann unsere Aufgabe,
aus dem Talent etwas zu machen.
Hat man Freude, kann man viel
aus der Stimme herausholen.
Mit Freude
kann man extrem viel erreichen.
Freudig: Nimm dir Zyt zum Grüesse!
# Nimm dir ...
- Nein.
* Sie gibt verschiedene Töne vor. *
# Nimm dir Zyt zum Grüesse!
# Alles strahlet zrug.
In die Mitte des Fusses,
gerade runter und dann gleich hoch.
* Stimmübungen *
Ich unterrichte sehr gerne.
Wenn man unterrichtet,
sollte man die Neugier,
die man als Kind hatte,
das Leben lang erhalten.
* Beschwingter Jodelgesang *
Ich kann klar sagen:
Ja, jodeln ist lernbar.
Aber es braucht natürlich
gewisse Gegebenheiten.
Wenn jemand kein Musikgehör hat,
ist es ein härterer Prozess.
Es ist noch kein Gelehrter
vom Himmel gefallen.
Man muss üben.
Es ist eine Technik.
Aber wenn man sich
auf verschiedenen Ebenen
mit Singen, Jodeln und der Stimme,
aber auch hörend
mit der Literatur auseinandersetzt,
kann man es sicher lernen.
Die Frage ist immer,
was man erreichen will.
* Stimmübungen *
Man unterscheidet beim Jodeln
zwischen Jodellied -
das ist mit Text, während der
Refrain auf Silben gejodelt wird -
und Naturjodel, der regional
andere Bezeichnungen hat.
In Innerrhoden
nennt man ihn Rugguuseli,
in Ausserrhoden Zäuerli.
Jetzt gerade sangen wir einen Juiz,
einen Obwaldner Naturjodel,
und zwar weil zwei Obwaldner
im Chor singen.
Hier in der Innerschweiz
spricht man von Jutzen
und im Toggenburg von Johlen.
Es gibt regionale Bezeichnungen,
es ist aber immer
der Naturjodel gemeint.
Und Naturjodel
ist Jodel gänzlich ohne Text.
* Beschwingter Jodelgesang *
Für jemanden,
der nicht von hier ist,
würden wir einen Naturjutz nehmen,
um Jodeln zu präsentieren,
also ein Lied ohne Worte.
Erstens aus sprachlichen Gründen,
damit man nicht
auf den Text hören muss,
und zweitens,
weil es das Traditionelle ist.
Es ist uns wichtig,
Aussenstehenden
traditionellere Dinge zu zeigen.
Wenn man nur ein Lied singt,
würden wir einen Naturjutz nehmen.
* Beschwingter Jodelgesang *
Ich glaube auch, ein Naturjutz.
Oder dann
"Jetzt wemmer eis jödele".
Stimmt.
- Das ist sehr spannend.
Der Text ist nicht so schwierig -
sagen wir es so -,
aber es ist wie eine Jodelreise
durch die Schweiz,
bei der man in der Innerschweiz
startet und jodelt wie dort.
# Wie d'Innerschwiizer tüend jödele,
luschtig si.
Dann geht's ins Appenzell.
Und wohin noch?
Nach Bern.
- Genau.
Es ist ein etwas schnelleres,
rassigeres Lied.
* Beschwingter Jodelgesang *
Die Geschwister Monney
sind ein gutes Beispiel
für zwei junge Frauen,
die sehr leidenschaftlich jodeln.
* Gefühlvoller Jodelgesang *
Sie singen wirklich super.
Sie kommen in der Tracht
sehr traditionell daher.
Es ist lustig zu sehen,
dass beides möglich ist.
Sie sind ein gutes Beispiel dafür,
dass man die Tradition leben
und in der Tracht jodeln kann,
aber doch auch durch die Welt ziehen
und noch andere Musik hören kann.
# Lady, running down to the riptide,
taken away to the dark side.
# I wanna be your left-hand man.
Solche Dinge sehe ich immer gern.
Das tut uns gut.
Es sind nicht immer die Gleichen,
die Volksmusik machen.
Unterschiedliche Menschen
finden darin etwas.
# I boue mir myni Tröim uf
rund um di
# und male se scharlachrot a.
Das geht in die Sparte Mundart,
was auch Volksmusik sein kann.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
auch Lieder aus der Mundart
oder anderen Stilrichtungen
können zu Volksliedern werden,
wenn sie im Volksohr
gespeichert sind.
Wir sind sehr auf Traditionen aus,
finden es aber auch wunderbar,
wenn man mit der Zeit geht
und Traditionen wandeln oder neue
Dinge zu Traditionen machen kann.
* Gefühlvoller Jodelgesang *
"Jodel meets Classic"
ist ein sehr spannender Event.
Dort wurde versucht, klassische
Musik und Jodel zusammenzuführen.
Das mag auf den ersten Blick
absurd klingen,
auf den zweiten
ist es aber gar nicht so absurd,
weil es sehr gut zusammenpasst -
was sie auch zeigten.
Es ist ein megagutes Beispiel dafür,
wie man das mischen kann,
und wie wichtig es ist,
um die Musik weiterzubringen.
# Der Winter isch gange,
der Früehlig isch cho.
# Die oberschte Weidene
blüehet is scho.
Vom Jodel leben zu können,
ist in der Schweiz sehr schwierig.
Wir durften schon ganz viel erleben.
Dafür sind wir dankbar.
Seien es Auftritte
in der Schweiz selber,
an unzähligen Jodlerabenden
oder an Jodlerfesten,
an die wir gehen durften.
Das ist so schön.
Und dann auch das Internationale.
Wir durften mal nach China.
Das sind unglaublich schöne
Erfahrungen, die man macht.
Aber es reicht natürlich nicht,
einfach nur zu singen.
Das ist
auch nicht unbedingt schlecht.
Früher wünschten wir uns,
davon leben zu können,
aber ich glaube, solange es
ein ausgeprägtes Hobby bleibt,
ist das Herz anders dabei.
Erfolg in der Volksmusik?
Ich weiss nicht.
Verkauf von vielen CDs
kann es nicht sein.
In der Volksmusik
nehme ich mir das Recht heraus,
nichts entsprechen zu wollen.
Wenn ich mit dem, was ich mache,
zufrieden bin,
ist das Erfolg genug.
In der Volksmusik hat nicht
der Beste am meisten Erfolg.
Das Publikum entscheidet.
Dabei geht es um gefallen
und nicht gefallen.
Ein alter Mann sagte mir mal,
Musik zu machen sei keine Kunst,
aber Musik zu verkaufen schon.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Erfolg ist, wenn man auch
im hohen Alter noch engagiert wird.
Das ich jetzt ja habe.
In jungen Jahren dachte man schon,
es wäre super,
Tausende CDs zu verkaufen,
sodass man fast davon leben könnte.
Wir merkten aber relativ bald,
dass das nicht klappen wird.
Es ist ein Dank, den man erhält,
wenn man Erfolg hat.
Ich glaube,
das brauchen wir alle ein wenig.
Mein Traum ist,
finanziell frei zu sein
und nur noch das zu machen,
was ich geil finde,
also das Experimentieren mit Musik.
Reich wird man sicher nicht,
aber das ist auch nicht
das Wichtigste im Leben.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Talent ist ein wichtiger Aspekt
in dieser Musik.
Ich merkte früh,
dass ich talentiert bin.
Ich hätte gerne Musik studiert,
aber meine Eltern meinten,
ich solle erst
etwas Richtiges lernen.
Das war damals halt so.
Ich bin ihnen dankbar.
Mit dem,
was ich musikalisch fühlen konnte,
wurde ich
zum glücklichsten Menschen.
Der wichtigste Erfolg in der Musik:
Freude daran zu haben.
# Olé!
Wir erhalten viele Komplimente
von Leuten,
die finden, wir seien auf der Bühne
so sympathisch.
Wir lachen und grüssen alle.
Ich glaube,
das ist ganz entscheidend.
Es bringt nichts,
wenn man wie ein Herrgott spielt,
aber dasitzt wie ein Stein.
Wenn die Leute sehen,
dass du Freude hast,
freuen sie sich auch.
Dann sehen sie gerne zu.
Einen Stein
sieht man nicht lange an.
An Carlo Brunner beeindruckt mich,
dass er trotz des Kommerziellen -
ich nenne es mal so -
immer seine Kapelle hatte
und dem Heirassa-Stil treu blieb.
Er spielte immer
auf einem sehr hohen Niveau.
Als ich anfing,
Klarinette zu spielen,
hatte ich schon eine erste Platte.
Die Ländlerschiene
sprach mich sofort an.
Jost Ribary war bereits gestorben.
Und Carlo Brunner war 30,
lebte noch und gab Vollgas.
Ihn konnte man erleben.
Er war für mich ein grosses Vorbild.
Man nennt ihn nicht umsonst
"Ländlerkönig".
Wenn man ausserhalb der Szene
nach einem Namen fragt,
wird es zu 99 % Carlo Brunner sein.
Ich hatte nie den Anspruch,
der Beste zu sein.
Der Erfolgreichste kann man werden,
wenn man etwas komponiert
und interpretiert,
das den Leuten
einfach wahnsinnig gefällt.
Ich komponiere nicht mehr.
Ich habe einige solche Ordner
mit Kompositionen.
In diesem Ordner allein
sind es rund 400.
Wenn ich etwas Neues bräuchte,
könnte ich erst im Fundus schauen.
Die Auswahl ist unendlich.
Da ist alles drin: von Schottisch,
bis Ländler, Märsche, Slow ...
Alles, was das Herz begehrt.
Da finde ich immer etwas.
Es heisst oft, mit der Ländlermusik
gehe es den Bach runter.
Das stimmt nicht. Es gibt viele
junge und gute Volksmusikanten.
Wir stellen Ihnen Carlo
an der Klarinette vor.
Hier sehen Sie Fredi, einen kleinen
Lausbuben von elf, zwölf Jahren,
der Klavier spielt.
Drücken Sie den beiden
Küsnachter Leugeli die Daumen,
Fredi und Carlo.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Mein erster TV-Auftritt
war sehr speziell.
Ich spielte an einem Konzert.
Da kam Wysel Gyr,
eine Legende in der Volksmusik,
plötzlich zu mir und fragte:
"Willst du im Fernsehen auftreten?"
Ich war natürlich fasziniert
und begeistert.
Mein erster Erfolg
war sicher dieser Fernsehauftritt.
Ich erhielt Post
aus der ganzen Schweiz:
Es sei toll, dass wieder ein Junger
Ländlermusik mache.
Dieser Fernsehauftritt
brachte mir natürlich
einen grossen Namen ein.
Ich durfte als 13-Jähriger anfangen.
Ich spielte einfach ein bisschen,
ich ging noch zur Schule.
Ich hatte Freude an der Musik,
die ich vom Vater gelernt hatte.
Dann kam ich in eine Plattenfirma
und durfte jung Platten aufnehmen.
Ein Fox, den nicht Carlo,
sondern sein Vater Ernst Brunner
schrieb: "Häsch Zyt?"
Fast die ganze Familie Brunner
macht da mit.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
# Häsch Zyt, häsch Zyt?
# Es Stündli oder zwei?
# Dänn mached mir en Musikantäträff
bi eus dihei.
# Häsch Zyt?
Die Herrlichkeit, die man
um die geliebte Musik herum hat -
da merkt man, dass sie
kein grosses Publikum anspricht.
Also fing man an, sich zu fragen,
was man machen könnte,
um ein breiteres Publikum
anzusprechen.
So wurde man eben kommerzieller.
Man schrieb einfachere Sachen
und änderte auch mal die Besetzung.
Da merkte man,
dass man im Schlagerbereich
und instrumental mit Saxofonmelodien
den grösseren Erfolg hatte.
Ich habe etwas Mühe damit,
dass das Publikum einfachere,
banalere oder primitivere Musik hört
und man damit eher Erfolg hat.
In meiner Anfangskarriere ging es
eine Zeit lang eher nach oben.
Viele Kollegen
entwickelten sich weiter
und waren z.T.
auch ausgebildete Volksmusiker.
Ich finde es schade,
dass genau diese meines Erachtens
zu wenig Erfolg haben.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Willi Valotti war für mich immer
ein Riesenvorbild.
Er spielt aus dem Herzen,
er ist ein Vollblutmusiker.
Mit 15, 16
ging ich zu ihm in den Unterricht.
Er eröffnete mir
eine riesige musikalische Welt.
Als wir jung waren und anfingen
und viele kritisierten,
was wir taten,
verteidigte er uns immer.
Er suchte den grossen Erfolg nie,
er hatte ihn einfach -
mit seiner Leidenschaft
für die Musik.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
(Valotti) Als aktiver Musiker kann
man verschiedene Richtungen wählen.
Man kann z.B. für eine gute Show
auf der Bühne trainieren.
Dann muss man vielleicht
nicht so gut spielen können,
aber eine gute Bühnenpräsenz haben.
Und dann gibt es solche,
die beides haben.
Ich war auf der Bühne
eher der ruhige Typ
und machte die Musik,
die mich selbst ansprach.
Dann hat man halt ein kleineres
Publikum, das diese Musik schätzt.
Ich spreche die Schlagerszene an.
Die müssen so komponieren,
damit möglichst alle mitsingen
können und es ein Hit wird.
Im Fernsehen zu spielen,
war ein Wahnsinnserfolg.
Mit 14 Jahren spielte ich
in der Kapelle Echo vom Hemberg.
Damals war es so -
das darf ich auch sagen -,
dass wirklich nur die Allerbesten
der Schweizer Volksmusik
im Fernsehen oder auch im Radio
spielen durften.
Es gab strenge
musikalisch ausgebildete Leute,
die die Formationen
nach Hause schickten,
wenn jemand falsch spielte.
Das ist heute nicht mehr der Fall.
* Musik über Lautsprecher *
Das ist das Archiv.
Hier gibt es unzählige Platten
und alles, was man sammelt.
U.a. gibt es hier
auch ein Weihnachtsland.
Da dachten wir an die Kinder.
Das machte mein Schatz Erika.
Das ist süss.
Da fährt noch eine Eisenbahn -
auch bezeichnend für mich.
Einfach viel Zeug, das mir gefällt.
Fast ein Museum.
Es ist alles voll mit Schallplatten.
Es sind über 2'500 Schallplatten.
Es gibt
eine richtige Musikgeschichte.
Das sind D'Ländlerkönig.
Das war auch
eine legendäre Produktion.
Alle Stilrichtungen vereint
mit zehn Musikern.
Die konnten alle Stilrichtungen
der Schweiz spielen.
* Fröhliche Musik *
# Mir fahre mit dr Bahn.
# Mit Dampf, ohni Chrampf.
D'Ländlerkönig haben mit dem zu tun,
was wir schon angesprochen haben:
Erfolg.
Man wollte die Volksmusik
und Ländlermusik mehr verbreiten
und ein grösseres Publikum
erreichen.
So machte man einen Haufen
aus bekannten Volksmusikern.
Das war damals die Idee
von Sepp Trütsch.
Das war unglaublich.
Ich moderierte das Ganze
und fragte das Publikum,
was es hören wolle.
Es konnte einfach
einen Titel nennen,
z.B. "Dr Wentalaschieber".
Ich fragte, wer das spielen solle.
Da hiess es z.B.:
"Zinsli am Klavier."
Dann musste Zinsli ans Klavier.
Man konnte das zusammenmischen.
Das war eines der Erfolgserlebnisse.
Mein bekanntestes Stück ...
Äh ...
Das hat mich bis heute
über Wasser gehalten: "Rinaldo".
Das ist ein Stück,
das viele Volksmusikakkordeonisten
im Programm haben.
Es ist der einzige Gassenhauer,
den ich komponierte.
* Rasante Ländlermusik *
Ich überlegte mir nie,
wie ich Erfolg haben könnte.
Ich machte einfach meine Musik.
Das schönste Erlebnis war,
als ich zur Kapelle Heirassa kam.
Ich machte aber nichts,
sondern spielte einfach.
Anscheinend
war ich gut genug für sie.
Wir waren
eine sehr erfolgreiche Kapelle.
Wir hatten Auftritte
in der ganzen Schweiz.
Ich musste nie überlegen,
wie ich Erfolg haben könnte.
Ich wollte gar nicht mehr Erfolg.
Für mich reichte das.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Ich sollte alle begrüssen,
aber dann bin ich um 12 Uhr
noch dran.
Hoi.
Erfolg bedeutet für mich,
wenn man gefragt ist,
also wenn nicht alle Leute gehen,
wenn man zu spielen beginnt,
sondern vielleicht stehen bleiben.
Wenn man in einem Restaurant
oder Konzertsaal spielt,
ist der Erfolg einfach
die Anerkennung des Publikums.
Wenn das Publikum strahlt.
In letzter Zeit kamen
auch Standing Ovations in Mode.
Das gab es früher nicht,
obwohl wir da
nicht schlechter spielten.
Für mich persönlich ist Erfolg,
Freude an dem zu haben, was ich tue.
Wenn man das macht, was man gerne
tut, hat man schon gewonnen.
Die Freude
ist einfach das Allerwichtigste.
Wenn man nur einigen
eine Riesenfreude machen kann,
ist das grossartig.
Erfolg ist für uns,
wenn wir einen guten Abend hatten
und die Leute Freude hatten -
das tut schon gut.
Im Hip-Hop geht es um Geld,
fette Karren und Villas,
in der Volksmusik
geht es eher darum,
wer in den schönsten Lokalen
die beste Stimmung erreicht hat.
Oder wer einen alten Tanz
von vor 50, 60, 70 Jahren
am genauesten nachspielen kann.
Oder wer schon mit wem Musik machte.
Erfolg wird sicher anders definiert
als in anderen Sparten.
Die verklemmte Bescheidenheit
ist generell
ein Schweizer Identitätsmerkmal.
Wir mögen den Durschnitt.
Wenn jemand zu erfolgreich ist,
gibt es schnell sehr viel Gegenwind.
* Markanter Jodelgesang *
Erfolg ... Ja ...
Für mich ist da etwas,
das man kreiert hat.
Daraus erfolgt etwas, das passiert.
In meinem Fall musste ich
ziemlich fest an mich glauben.
Ich glaubte an Jutzerkurse.
Ich wusste, dass es möglich war.
Und heute läuft es sehr gut.
Der Erfolg von Heimweh,
dass wir so viele Alben verkauften -
wir haben den Diamant-Award
für über 150'000 verkaufte Alben -
zeigt, dass die Leute
nach wie vor ein Bedürfnis haben
nach Liedern mit Geschichten,
mit denen sie sich
identifizieren können.
Heimweh ist die heile Welt -
aber was spricht dagegen,
über Gutes und Schönes zu singen?
# Müend nid truure um mich.
# Ich bi immer no da.
Heimweh ist unglaublich erfolgreich.
Es ist beeindruckend,
wie sie auf Tournee gehen
und in jedem Kaff Säle
mit 500-700 Leuten füllen.
Der grösste Saal in der Gegend
ist innert drei Tagen ausverkauft.
Das funktioniert gut.
Musikalisch
kann ich damit nichts anfangen.
Es ist doch sehr überraschungsfrei.
Aber sie haben durchaus Qualität.
Frowin Neff und Bernhard Betschart
sind hervorragende Jodler.
Vielleicht ist es eine Chance,
dass Dinge, die während 50 Jahren
auseinanderdrifteten,
wieder zusammenkommen.
Das ist übrigens jene Formation,
mit der ich
am wenigsten Aufwand habe,
die aber am erfolgreichsten ist.
Ich sehe es definitiv
als Volksmusik: Musik fürs Volk.
# Isch äis, wo ewig hebt.
Es ist Musik, die mit kommerziellem
Hintergrund produziert wird,
aber gewisse volksmusikalische
Elemente beinhaltet.
Das per se
ist aber noch keine Volksmusik.
Das ist eigentlich Cross-over.
Wer weiss,
vielleicht entwickelt es sich so,
dass man in 20 Jahren
davon als Volksmusik spricht.
Ich fahre gerade Richtung Zürich
zu HitMill.
Ich treffe Georg Schlunegger,
den musikalischen Leiter
von Heimweh.
Er hat Ideen für ein neues Lied,
die wir uns gemeinsam ansehen.
(Ringli)
HitMill macht einen guten Job.
Es ist ein Studio, das klar
im kommerziellen Bereich tätig ist
und nicht Kunst voranbringen will.
Sie machen Musik, um ein möglichst
breites Publikum zu erreichen.
Ich hoffe aber schon,
dass die Auseinandersetzung,
die nie stattgefunden hat ...
Ländlermusik
und zeitgemässe Populärmusik
waren seit 70 Jahren
kein Thema mehr.
Es wäre eine Chance,
das näher zusammenzubringen.
# So wie dazumal.
* Sanfter Jodelgesang *
Den Gesang, aus dem er kommt,
den Naturjutz, den spürt man.
Er hat auch bei Liedern mit Text
eine andere Herangehensweise
ans Singen als andere Sänger,
und das macht ihn einzigartig.
Hast du Ideen?
- Ja.
Das ist immer gut.
- Ich kann dir etwas zeigen.
Ich hatte die Idee,
etwas über Jahreszeiten zu machen.
Das hier ...
* Tonabfolge *
Das ist die Hauptmelodie
mit dem Klavier.
Es besteht die Möglichkeit,
das zu jodeln.
Du bist hier ...
* Tonabfolge *
... ungefähr im E.
* Jodeln *
Da ginge es in die Kopfstimme.
- Genau.
* Gefühlvoller Jodelgesang
mit Klavierbegleitung *
Die Ausgangsidee von Heimweh
in Bezug auf die Lieder war,
einen anderen Weg als andere Chöre
zu gehen.
Die Poplieder
beinhalten aber viele rurale Themen
aus der Landschaft
und dem Leben in den Bergen.
Gleichzeitig kommt noch dazu,
dass die Lieder eine Anlehnung
an den Jodel der Volksmusik haben.
Viele Leute finden sich
in dieser Art Musik wieder.
Aber nicht nur in der Musik,
sondern auch in den Texten.
# Für mich ist es etwas hoch.
# Mir sind wie d'Jahreszyte.
# Mir chömid und mir gönd.
# Wie Früehlig, Summer,
Herbscht und Winter
# Spure hinderlönd.
Noch mal.
# Mir sind ...
# Mir sind wie d'Jahreszyte.
# Am ne Früehligstag erwacht.
# Wie d'Chnoschpe, wo zum erschte Mal
dur de Schnee i d'Höchi ragt.
# Dur de Schnee i d'Höchi ragt.
* Jodeln *
Erfolgreich wird man,
wenn man Musik macht,
die die Leute hören wollen,
und nicht, wenn man den Leuten
die eigene Musik aufdrückt.
Es gibt eine Schnittmenge
zwischen der eigenen Verwirklichung
und dem,
womit man das Publikum erreicht.
Bei Heimweh
gibt es viele Männer im Chor,
die sonst ganz andere Musik machen
und trotzdem bei Heimweh dabei sind
und damit Riesenerfolg haben.
Um mit Volksmusik
erfolgreich zu sein,
brauchte es schon immer
eine Anlehnung
an die gerade aktuelle
und erfolgreiche Popmusik.
Erinnern wir uns an Bossbuebe
und "s'Träumli".
# S'isch ja nur
es chlises Träumli gsi.
Solche Gratwanderungen,
in denen man Neues
Richtung Pop ausprobierte,
funktionierten immer sehr gut.
Die Hörgewohnheit der breiten Masse,
mit dem Swing in den 50er-Jahren
oder heute mit Hip-Hop ...
# Das isch Musig, Volksmusig.
# Mir sind Stolzmusig,
us nüt wird Goldmusig.
(Schlunegger)
Kann man die mit einer Anlehnung
an volksmusikalische Klänge
aufgreifen,
trifft das immer
auf breites Publikum.
Die Leute erkennen sich wieder, da
es zur nationalen Identität gehört.
Andererseits geht man neue Wege und
es hat etwas Modernes und Frisches.
Danke!
(Ringli) Es ist eine Chance
und ein Fluch,
dass die Schweizer Volksmusik
langsam in der Popkultur ankommt.
Es ist schön,
dass sie mehr Aufmerksamkeit erhält.
Man könnte sie weltweit verfolgen.
Es gibt einen Bezug zum Lokalen.
Umgekehrt gibt es dann
so etwas wie die Büetzer Buebe,
die in die übliche Kommerzschiene
abdrifteten.
Da werden Versatzstücke
aus der Volksmusik genommen,
um ein grosses Publikum
zu erreichen.
So.
Ich mache dir kurz eine Spur.
* Ruhige Klaviermusik *
Ich glaube, so ist es gut.
Ich lasse es von Anfang an laufen.
- Sehr gerne.
Soll ich den ersten Teil
etwas feiner oder gleich ...
Nein, du darfst ...
- ... sofort rein?
# Mir sind wie d'Jahreszyte.
Das muss sofort da sein.
- Gut. Super. Cool.
# Mir sind wie d'Jahreszyte.
# Mir chömid und mir gönd.
# Wie Früehlig, Summer, Herbscht
und Winter Spure hinderlönd.
# Üsi Spure hinderlönd.
Ich verstehe gut,
dass der Männerchor Heimweh
von den Medien
auch kritisch betrachtet wird.
Ähm ...
Das würde ich auch tun,
wäre ich nicht dabei.
Wenn etwas erfolgreich ist,
wird man meistens auch kritisch
und fragt sich, ob das echt ist.
Es gibt sehr viele Kritiker,
die unsere Musik nicht mögen
und finden, es sei keine Volksmusik.
Die haben auch recht, da viele
Genres zusammengemischt werden.
Trotzdem denke ich, dass wir die Tür
zur Volksmusik öffnen können.
Wir haben die Chance,
Leute zum klassischen Jodel
zu bringen,
die den Zugang sonst
vielleicht nicht gefunden hätten.
Der Swiss Music Award
für den Best Breaking Act 2017
geht an Schluneggers Heimweh.
(Valotti) Diese Preise
tragen natürlich zum Erfolg bei,
da viele Leute einen nach Preisen
und Auszeichnungen einstufen.
Jeder, der Konzerte veranstaltet,
muss ja schauen,
dass er Publikum hat.
Wenn er schreibt,
dass jemand mit dem Prix Walo,
dem Goldenen Violinschlüssel
oder sonst etwas kommt,
denken viele,
dass man sich das ansehen muss,
auch wenn sie den Namen
vielleicht gar nicht kennen.
Das trägt natürlich dazu bei,
das ist ganz logisch.
Den Preis gewinnt ...
Carlo, hast du ein Klavier zu Hause?
Carlo Brunner.
Soll man davon erzählen?
Natürlich
durfte ich viele Preise gewinnen.
Einschneidend war sicher ...
... dieser Preis hier.
Das war 1987,
der Grand Prix der Volksmusik.
Dieses Ding hier nennt der Bergmann
"weisses Gold der Erde".
Der Chemiker bezeichnet es
als "hexagonales Mineral
aus reinstem Siliciumdioxid".
Und für den Musiker
oder den Interpreten,
der es heute Abend gewinnt,
ist es
der Grand Prix der Volksmusik,
die höchste Auszeichnung der volks-
tümlichen Musik bzw. Volksmusik.
Der Grand Prix der Volksmusik
war etwas vom Besten,
das die Schweizer Schallplatten-
industrie haben konnte.
V.a. für uns,
die den Mittelweg wählten
und volkstümliche Unterhaltungsmusik
und Schlagermusik produzierten,
war es eine Chance,
neue Künstler
einem grossen Publikum vorzustellen.
In diesen 25 Jahren
wurden etliche Stars geboren,
die man vorher nicht kannte,
wie auch meine Schwester,
Maja Brunner.
* Beschwingte Musik *
# Wenn's nur no Pizza git
und nie meh Cervelat.
# Wenn nur Martini Dry,
aber kei Moscht chasch ha.
Da holten wir den Sieg.
Das war für uns
eine grosse Überraschung.
Es war auf Schweizerdeutsch gesungen
und die Besetzung
war wie eine Ländlerkapelle.
Das funktionierte international.
Darauf sind wir sehr stolz.
# Das chunnt eus spanisch vor.
# Das chunnt eus
gopferdeckel spanisch vor.
Mit dem Grand Prix
waren wir sehr erfolgreich.
Komponiert
wurde es von Carlo Brunner.
Die Komposition
stammt von Carlo Brunner.
Der letzte
der fünf Schweizer Beiträge
beim diesjährigen
Grand Prix der Volksmusik
wurde von Carlo Brunner komponiert.
Manchmal waren mehrere eigene Titel
in der Ausscheidung,
worüber sich manche
nicht so freuten.
"Es gewinnt immer der Gleiche."
"Der ist immer dabei."
Wir machten einfach mit -
wie alle anderen.
Und ich finde, dass wir
sehr professionell produzierten.
Wir dachten dann, dass wir uns
vielleicht verstecken müssen.
Mit einem anderen Namen
wäre es nicht immer Carlo Brunner,
also nahm ich ein Pseudonym an:
Karl Fontana.
Damit komponierte ich sehr viel.
Damit war ich genauso erfolgreich.
Aus der Schweiz:
die Siegerin Monique.
Das ist der Grand Prix.
Halte ihn hoch!
Du hast ihn dir redlich verdient.
* Applaus *
Das Lied wurde dir von Karl Fontana
fast auf den Leib geschrieben.
# Einmal so, einmal so
und auch einmal so lala.
Bis das dann auch aufgedeckt wurde.
"Passt auf, Carlo Brunner
ist auch Karl Fontana."
Ein Jahr später
gab ich wieder Titel ein,
die wiederum erfolgreich waren,
aber unter anderem Namen.
Dann kamen Leute zu mir:
"Carlo, hast du gesehen?"
"Es gibt noch andere,
die komponieren können,
nämlich Franz Lehner."
Und das war auch ich.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Ich mag beides sehr gerne:
Ich habe Freude
an den Traditionellen.
Dann gibt es aber auch solche,
die etwas probieren
und aus sich herauskommen.
Das finde ich genial:
einfach probieren.
Nicht sofort sagen, dass es Mist sei
und nicht hierhergehöre.
Man könnte es auch anders sagen:
"Das ist nicht unbedingt das,
was mir gefällt."
Jede Musik hat ihre Berechtigung.
Dass die Jungen heute
etwas abweichen
und manchmal etwas einbauen
und noch etwas Kunst einbringen -
damit muss man einfach leben.
Wenn man offen wird,
ist es plötzlich
einfach keine Tradition mehr.
Die Traditionen
sind uns schon sehr wichtig.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Als junger Bursche wollte man halt
ein wenig gegen den Strom schwimmen.
Das Örgeli
sah dann vielleicht nicht aus
wie das von Peter Zinsli.
Das war die Aussage.
Ein bisschen revolutionär.
Ich finde es gut,
dass es vorwärtsgeht,
solange man den musikalischen Akzent
der Tradition auch beibehält.
Dann finde ich es eine gute Sache.
Die Wurzeln muss man immer kennen,
wenn man etwas pflegt -
sei es eine Pflanze oder Musik.
Wenn ich es direkt sagen darf:
Ich liebe eher
die traditionelle Musik.
Viele haben Angst vor Veränderung
und sehen nur das Schlechte darin.
Veränderung ist aber eigentlich
die einzige Konstante.
Alles verändert sich.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Heute ist der Neue Silvester.
In Urnäsch
findet das Silvesterchlausen statt.
Wir gehen auch am Alten Silvester,
dem 13. Januar
nach dem julianischen Kalender.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Ich gehe chlausen,
seit ich etwa vier oder fünf war.
Ich ging als Junge und die Eltern
halfen bei der Vorbereitung.
Ich hatte das Glück,
acht Geschwister zu haben:
fünf Brüder und drei Schwestern.
Vater und Mutter
waren mit dem Brauch tief verbunden.
Jetzt bin ich 47.
Es reizt mich immer noch.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Für uns sind diese beiden Tage
die wichtigsten Tage.
Wir sind tief verbunden damit.
Da nimmt man den Aufwand
gerne auf sich.
Man ist Abend für Abend dabei.
Es beginnt mit der Planung,
was man machen wird.
Man arbeitet Nächte lang daran.
Bis man das Muster
und die Ideen hat, dauert es lange.
(Frau) Hast du noch Weisswein?
- Ja, dort.
Wir gehen von Haus zu Haus,
meistens mit drei Zäuerli.
Dazwischen haben wir die Schelle.
Damit vertreibt man
die bösen Geister.
* Schellen, Jodelgesang *
Tradition ist halt einfach ...
Wie soll ich das sagen?
Es ist so alt...
Es ist nicht altertümlich ...
Diese Klänge und alles, das Zäuerli,
das muss man im Herzen tragen.
Das kann man nicht einfach lernen
und denken,
dass man einfach mal zauern
und jodeln gehen kann.
Wir sind da schon noch
in der Volksmusik verwurzelt.
Das ist uns sehr wichtig.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
* Rhythmische Technomusik *
Ich finde, Techno- und Ländlermusik
sind ziemlich ähnlich.
Für mich ist es das gleiche Feeling.
Es ist Tanzmusik
mit zwei verschiedenen Klangfarben,
die man kennt - oder nicht kennt.
* Rhythmische Musik *
* Rhythmische Bassklänge *
Ich mache v.a. Ländlermusik.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Und ich bin auch
im Live-Techno tätig.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass ich beides brauche.
Wenn ich nur urchige Musik mache,
brauche ich noch etwas anderes.
Und wenn ich nur Techno spiele,
bin ich auch unzufrieden.
Pirmin Huber ist sehr auf dem Punkt,
wenn er spielt,
aber er ist im Kopf
immer einen Schritt weiter.
Er hat Tausende Ideen,
denen er nachjagt.
Das gefällt mir.
(Wyss) Er ist wohl einer der
besten Kontrabassisten der Szene.
und ein super Beispiel dafür,
was aus der Tradition
spriessen kann.
* Lockere Technomusik *
Mit Stereo Kulisse
spielen wir v.a. in Klubs.
* Lockere Technomusik *
Also ab Mitternacht
oder 2 Uhr nachts.
Es geht immer schön
mit den anderen Konzerten auf.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Mit Ambäck spielen wir
viele alte Muotathaler Stücke
eines alten Geigers.
Der spielte auf eine Art Geige,
von der man sagen kann,
sie sei entweder jenseits
oder topmodern.
Bei Altem kann man
eben auch "Neues" entdecken.
(Huber) Mit Gläuffig
spielen wir v.a. urchige Musik,
aber auch neue Volksmusik -
was immer "neu" heissen mag.
Neue Volksmusik
hat für mich persönlich
auch mit anderen Einflüssen zu tun,
mit Grooves.
Das ist für mich "das Neue".
Es gibt viele Leute,
die schon lange darauf warten,
dass Volksmusik anders tönt,
da es 60 Jahre lang gleich klang.
Ich möchte Markus Flückiger
nicht in ein schlechtes Licht
stellen,
aber er brachte mal
eine schöne Definition.
Der Unterschied sei:
Die Alten rauchen Krumme,
die Jungen Konische.
Es geht weiter, als er je ahnte.
Die Zeiten verändern sich.
Heute konsumiert man
andere Substanzen als früher,
also braucht es auch
eine andere Musik als früher.
Ich erinnere mich gar nicht,
das mal gesagt zu haben.
Die Bezeichnung
"Neue Volksmusik" ...
Es brauchte einen neuen Begriff,
da Volksmusik oft
tradierte Musik ist.
Über Jahre oder Jahrzehnte
an dieser Tradition festzuhalten,
hatte zur Folge,
dass sich der Inhalt lange Zeit
nicht mehr veränderte.
Das Schwyzerörgeli-Duett
Edgar Ott und Markus Flückiger.
Sie spielen uns
ein sehr interessantes
und kurzweiliges Stück:
"s'Kamel im Ybrig".
Wenn Sie genau hinhören,
hören Sie darin
orientalische Stilelemente.
Und wenn Sie viel Fantasie haben,
sehen Sie sogar
die Silhouette einer Kamelkarawane
am Horizont
einer unendlichen Sandwüste.
* Rasante Ländlermusik *
* Orientalische Klänge *
Markus Flückiger
war einer der Ersten -
v.a. auf dem Schwyzerörgeli -,
der die Ländlermusik und Volksmusik
weiterentwickelte
und mit neuen Einflüssen
in Verbindung brachte.
Er hat halt ...
Durch sein vielseitiges
und offenes Denken
konnte er in alle Richtungen
leuchten.
Durch sein Können,
aber auch durch seine grosszügige,
liebevolle Art
konnte er das entwickeln.
Er ist eine wandelnde
musikalische Ideenfabrik,
die einfach alle Einflüsse
problemlos in seine Art Musik
umsetzen kann.
Er probiert alles Mögliche aus.
Trotzdem entdeckt man immer
seine Handschrift.
Das ist das Kompositorische.
Auf dem Instrument sind ihm ohnehin
keine Grenzen gesetzt.
* Rhythmische Schwyzerörgelimusik *
(Flückiger)
Ich suche gerne in der Musik.
Ich mag beides:
Ich mag die alte Volksmusik,
von der ich genau weiss,
wie sie klingen muss.
Das spiele ich dann auch so.
Ich mag es aber auch,
mich von allem zu lösen
und etwas zu suchen,
das es vielleicht noch nicht gab -
oder ich zumindest nicht kenne.
* Rhythmische Schwyzerörgelimusik *
An den ersten Fernsehauftritt
erinnere ich mich ziemlich gut.
Sie spielen uns von Altmeister
Jost Ribary "Champagner-Schottisch".
Das war natürlich
ein absolutes Highlight für uns,
die elf,
knapp zwölf Jahre alt waren.
Wir wurden von Sepp Trütsch
eingeladen.
* Beschwingte Klarinettenmusik *
(Engler) Was das Spielen betrifft,
ist Dani Häusler oberste Klasse.
Er spielt moderne Volksmusik.
Ab und zu etwas komisch,
auf gut Deutsch gesagt.
Aber immer wahnsinnig gut.
Man erkennt ihn sofort.
Wenn man ihn hört,
erkennt man ihn sofort.
Er hat einen eigenen Klang.
Das ist lustig.
Ich würde Dani Häusler -
mit vielen anderen zusammen -
ganz klar in die Ecke "Legende
und prägende Figur" stellen.
Er hat wahnsinnig viel bewirkt.
Er hat technisch und kompositorisch
neue Massstäbe gesetzt.
Was in den letzten 20, 30 Jahren
aus der Innerschweiz kam,
war stilprägend.
In der Jugend machte ich
v.a. traditionelle Volksmusik,
suchte aber schon damals eigene Wege
mit eigenen Stücken
und Kompositionen.
Ich kam damit aber nicht durch.
Es bestand immer der Eindruck,
dass man von uns
genau das hören wollte,
was andere vor uns
schon getan hatten.
Das war mir aber zu wenig
und dagegen wehrte ich mich auch.
Pareglish ist eine neue Band,
mit der wir schon mit der Besetzung
etwas Spezielles machen.
Der E-Bass macht z.B. sehr viel aus.
Zudem kommt der E-Bassist
nicht wie wir anderen
aus der Ländlerszene.
Dadurch
ergeben sich andere Resultate.
Wir klingen anders
als eine normale Volksmusik.
Es ist schräg.
Es ist eine aussergewöhnliche Gruppe
ausserhalb
der traditionellen Ländlermusik.
Ich sage es so:
etwas ausgeflippte Ländlermusik.
Volksmusik, die die Leute
vielleicht wieder mehr anspricht.
Crazy Ländler.
Dani Häusler und ich
kennen uns schon sehr lange.
Wir lernten uns relativ jung kennen,
also so ungefähr Anfang 20.
Mit Dani habe ich meine wilden
Zeiten erlebt und durchgemacht.
Das war dann ...
Das war mehr Rock'n'Roll
als Volksmusik.
Hip-Hop ist bei den Jungen
auch nicht nur
aus musikalischen Gründen so kultig,
sondern wegen
der vermittelten Lebenseinstellung.
Wir nannten es manchmal
"Sex, Drugs and Hudigäggeler".
Das ist kein Klischee.
Das gibt es wirklich.
Wie soll ich sagen?
Sex, Drugs and Rock'n'Roll.
Wir hörten natürlich
auch Rock'n'Roll
und liessen uns
auch davon beeinflussen.
Wir nahmen überall das Tolle heraus.
Das waren z.T. wilde Zeiten, ja.
Wir hatten natürlich
unzählige Groupies.
Nein, nein, das ist übertrieben,
aber wenn man jung,
gut und toll ist,
ergibt sich natürlich schon
das ein oder andere.
Ich kann kaum ausdrücken,
wie begeistert ich bin.
Es lupfte mich einfach.
Es lupfte mich fast vom Stuhl.
Dani Häusler und Markus Flückiger
sind die,
die Ende 90er-Jahre
zu einem regelrechten Knall
in der damals etwas eingefrorenen
Volksmusikszene führten.
Sie warfen
die damals festgeschriebenen Regeln
radikal über den Haufen
und schauten,
welche Volksmusik es noch gab,
v.a. auch im nordischen Raum.
"Wie können wir uns daran bedienen,
aber daraus etwas Eigenes machen?"
Es muss nicht immer traditionell,
urchig oder gar verstaubt klingen.
Es gibt viele junge Musikanten,
die gerne experimentieren.
Wie es dann klingt,
hören wir von Hujässler.
* Lockere Ländlermusik *
(Brülisauer) Manchmal muss man
über das Ziel hinausschiessen
und das Ganze
auch wieder etwas relativieren.
Das hat bei ihnen mit dem Übergang
zur Hauptformation Hujässler
wirklich stattgefunden.
Wir wollen Grenzen sprengen.
Es muss einfach Spass machen.
Früher, vor 20 oder 25 Jahren,
als wir Dinge suchten
oder ausprobierten
und die Musik etwas anders klang
als in den 70 Jahren zuvor -
wenn auch nur ein bisschen -,
gab es doch auch Anfeindungen.
Dir wird auch vorgeworfen,
mit deinem Stil
würdest du die Ländlermusik
verhunzen.
Wie ist deine Meinung dazu?
Ich spiele,
wie mir der Schnabel gewachsen ist.
In den Anfangszeiten gab es
vereinzelt negative Rückmeldungen.
Darüber lachte man.
Wir wollten denen
ja auch gar nicht gefallen.
* Lockere Ländlermusik *
Mittlerweile, nach über 20 Jahren,
darf man wohl sagen,
dass Hujässler inzwischen wieder
in der Tradition angekommen sind.
Sie zählen zur Tradition -
trotz Neuem,
was sie nach wie vor machen.
Darum sind Dani Häusler
und Markus Flückiger
wohl die wichtigsten Volksmusiker -
da sie es auch
von Berufs wegen tun -
der letzten rund 25 Jahre.
Zweimal Wasser mit Sprudel.
Wir sind in Berlin,
weil ich vom Kanton Schwyz
ein Atelier erhalten habe.
Ich hatte mich beworben.
Der Kanton Schwyz gibt jeweils
verschiedenen Künstlern ein Atelier,
damit sie kreativ arbeiten können.
Ich bin sehr dankbar,
dass ich das erhalten habe.
Jetzt habe ich die Möglichkeit,
genau im Thema,
mit dem ich mich gerade befasse -
mit Volksmusik und Elektronik -,
weiterzuarbeiten.
Meine Musik ist ziemlich frei
und hat immer eine Volksmusikbasis.
Man spürt immer den Ländlerbereich,
finde ich persönlich.
Es kann sein ...
... dass ich alles wegwerfe
und es nicht cool ist.
Das ist die Melodie.
* Rasante, rhythmische Melodie *
Das Ziel hier ist, mit dem Bass
eine groovige Line zu spielen
und darüber doch noch
eine "Volksmusikmelodie" zu haben.
Also für mich.
Der Prozess für mich ist immer,
einen gewissen Mood zu finden.
Ich beginne immer mit dem Groove,
immer von unten.
Entweder habe ich etwas im Kopf,
das einfach kommt,
oder ich probiere aus.
Und ich probiere so lange,
bis es mir gefällt.
Dann mache ich darauf eine Melodie.
Oder umgekehrt:
Ich habe eine Melodie,
was schon sehr viel bringt,
und muss damit dann
einen Groove oder Mood erschaffen.
Ich mache beides sehr gerne.
* Er klopft einen Rhythmus. *
In der Volksmusik darf man alles,
finde ich.
Ich finde den Gedanken,
dass man offen bleibt, sehr wichtig.
Was andere dann denken,
ist etwas anderes.
* Handyklingeln *
Hey! Alles klar? Hoi.
- Tipptopp.
Guten Tag.
- Gut gefahren?
Ja, tipptopp.
- Es lief bestens.
Willkommen in Berlin.
Ich bin megaglücklich,
dass meine Bandkollegen
von Stereo Kulisse
nach Berlin kommen.
Wir wollen irgendwo in der Stadt
zu spielen beginnen.
Dann schauen wir, was passiert.
Ich erhoffe mir,
dass das möglichst viele Leute hören
und sehen und uns dann auch folgen.
Auf Insta oder wo auch immer.
Dass sie auch sehen, was wir machen.
Klingt das?
- Ja.
* Rhythmische, elektronische Musik *
Es kamen megaviele Leute.
Sie tanzten
und blieben bis zum Schluss.
Wir machten in Berlin
eine megageile Technoparty.
Es war der Hammer.
Wirklich, ich bin begeistert.
(Marty)
# Und die Engel und Heiligen alle,
# sie sollen uns gnädig bewahren,
vor Übel, Unglück und Gefahren.
# An Leib und Seele, an Hab und Gut.
# Und erhalte das liebe Vieh
auch in treuer Hut.
# Und was sonst zur Alp gehören tut.
# Vor Hagel, Blitz und Wetterstrahl
und vor den bösen Geistern all.
# Gott schütze und segne allezeit,
von nun an bis in Ewigkeit.
# Ave, ave, ave Maria.
# Es walte Gott und Maria.
# Gelobt sei Jesus Christ
in alle Ewigkeit.
# Ja, Ewigkeit, Amen.
* Jauchzer *
Ich stehe um 6 Uhr auf.
Manchmal um 5.45 Uhr,
manchmal um 6.15 Uhr.
Ich bin da nicht so genau.
Jetzt hole ich die Kühe zum Melken.
# Chueli, chum!
# Chum!
# Chueli, chum, sa-sa-sa-sa.
Mein Vater und meine Mutter
juchzten beim Viehholen auch schon.
Und der Grossvater auch.
Ich weiss auch nicht,
aber das Vieh hört darauf.
# Chueli!
# Chömid go mälche!
Manchmal folgen sie etwas besser.
Wenn sie am Fressen sind,
sind sie mit dem Kopf dort
und kommen nicht.
Aber anfangs Sommer kann man
von unten rufen und alle kommen.
Die ersten zwei, drei Wochen.
Danach haben sie den Kopf am Boden.
Dann muss man sie manchmal holen.
Wir treiben sie runter
zum Melkstand.
Danach lassen wir sie wieder hoch
und sie dürfen wieder weiden.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Musik kommt oft nach dem Mittag
ins Spiel.
Da setze ich mich aufs Sofa
und spiele ein paar Tänze
auf dem Schwyzerörgeli.
Die Tradition in der Familie ...
Man wuchs einfach hinein.
Es bereitet wahnsinnig Freude,
Musik zu machen.
Wenn im Radio ein Tänzchen läuft,
lupft es einen einfach.
Ich weiss nicht -
das wurde wohl vererbt.
Ich kann nicht mal etwas dafür.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Vorbilder,
denen ich nacheifern will ...
Grossvater natürlich,
aber den kann man nicht nachmachen.
Der war ein Unikum.
Den erreicht man nicht.
Es ist halt einfach, wie es ist.
Mein Grossvater war Sity Domini.
Der war immer lustig und fröhlich.
Er hatte nie einen schlechten Tag,
soviel ich weiss.
Grossmutter könnte vielleicht
etwas anderes sagen.
Jemand, den ich persönlich kannte
und den ich
total beeindruckend fand,
war Sity Domini.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Frau, gib mir Wodka!
* Kräftiger Gesang *
Er schlug cool die Brücke
zwischen Tradition und Innovation.
Wenn man ihn spielen sah,
wie er sich auf der Bühne gab,
fragte man sich vielleicht,
was mit ihm los war.
Also ...
* Kräftiger Gesang *
Er hatte die Mentalität,
alles zu geben
und Lebensfreude zu versprühen.
* Stampfen *
Mich faszinierte, dass musikalisch
nicht immer alles stimmte,
wenn man sich die Aufnahmen anhörte.
Es war manchmal daneben und lustig
und alle konnten lachen.
Es war keine steife Art,
Musik zu machen,
bei der man auf jeden Ton
fixiert war.
Es war fröhlich:
Luschtig und fröhli läbt dr Löli.
Ein Büchel
ist wie ein gebogenes Alphorn.
Das ist der vom Grossvater.
Der hat manche Spucke hinterlassen.
Mit Dominis Büchel und Besen.
Viel Vergnügen mit den Illgauern!
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
* Sanfte Büchelklänge *
Ich blase manchmal rein.
Dann kommt etwas raus.
Im Sommer ist man fleissiger,
danach hat man wieder zu tun
und denkt, man habe keine Zeit,
und vergisst es.
Man hat immer anderes zu tun.
Dann geht es etwas unter.
Hier oben holt man es wieder hervor
und bläst rein.
Streng.
* Mehrstimmiger Gesang *
# Zum Traualtar wollen wir schreiten
und wir werden glücklich sein.
Also, wer beginnt?
Sonst müssen wir jemanden bestimmen.
- Dann gibt's nichts anderes.
Die zwei Alten.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Gehen wir so durch.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Wir sind im Urchigen -
ein Mix zwischen Polkamusik
und konzertant.
Es ist z.T. schwierige Musik
und sie ist v.a. rund.
Aber es ist auch
kein Fausthandschuhe-Tanz,
wie manche das nennen.
* Johlen *
(Mann) Unglaublich, unglaublich!
Bravo!
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Solche Abende gibt es hier öfter.
Es freut mich,
da man es zusammen
lustig haben kann.
Jeder ist, wie er ist.
Man redet Mist.
Niemand nimmt es ernst.
(Lachend) Manchmal schon.
Es ist einfach lustig und gesellig.
Und etwas Musik -
was will man mehr?
* Sie singen zur Ländlermusik. *
Wir machen Musik im Illgauer-Stil.
Das ist ein urchiger Stil,
würde ich sagen.
Nicht konzertant,
sondern eher Tanzmusik.
Wir mögen es natürlich,
wenn sie tanzen,
gäuerlen und bödelen.
Das mögen wir am liebsten.
Wenn es lustig ist, und alle
machen können, was sie möchten.
Es bringt ja nichts.
Lassen wir es bleiben.
# Das bringt doch nüt,
das nützt doch nüt,
# das treit doch gar nüt i.
Die Tradition ...
Man hört auch alles andere,
aber man muss trotzdem
auf dem Boden bleiben.
Wie gut ich das jetzt gesagt habe!
Das sagte mein Vater schon:
Luschtig und fröhli läbt dr Löli.
Und wie ihr sehen könnt,
sind wir das hier alle.
Aber wir sind wirklich lustig
und fröhlich.
* Fröhlicher Jodelgesang *
Klischees, Klischees ...
Es sei Bauernmusik.
Aber ein Stück weit
stimmt es ja auch.
Wenn man es erlebt, ist es anders.
Das ist bei jedem Musikstil so,
auch bei Pop oder Jazz.
Wenn man sich damit
nicht auseinandersetzt,
kommt man auch nicht rein
und es gefällt einem auch nicht.
Es gibt viele Vorurteile
zur Volksmusik.
Dass sie konservativ sei.
Traditionell.
Unter der Ländlermusik
gibt es vielleicht
mehr Rechtsorientierte -
vielleicht, weil viele
aus einer ländlichen Gegend kommen.
Aber das hat nichts mit der Musik
und den Traditionen zu tun,
sondern
mit der gesellschaftlichen Struktur.
Vorurteil heisst ja, dass man etwas
verurteilt, bevor man es kennt.
Das ist etwas sehr Schlechtes.
Man sollte es erst hören.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Die Frage nach der Politik
ist wohl eine
der am meisten gestellten Fragen.
Dieses Klischee,
dass Volksmusiker und Volks-
musikerinnen eher rechts denken.
Ich denke nicht,
dass man das schubladisieren kann.
Politisch ist man nicht immer
der gleichen Meinung.
Ich war lange in der SP,
aber das war nie ein Thema.
Wir können uns über Musik unter-
halten, andere Themen lassen wir.
Als Musikerin
bin ich nicht sehr politisch,
aber als Staatsbürgerin schon.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Volksmusik verbindet - seien es
Bauern, Älpler oder Städter.
Es ist einfach friedlich -
im Grossen und Ganzen.
Das ist ja das Wichtige.
Das ist ein Nussbaumer-Örgeli
von ungefähr 1925.
Es ist ein Standardmodell.
Der Klang des Schwyzerörgelis
hat mir immer gefallen.
Es gibt auch da
verschiedene Klangfarben
und eine grosse Vielseitigkeit
im Gebrauch.
Das ist einmalig.
Alois Lüönd ist auch
eine Schwyzerörgeli-Legende.
Mit seinen Mosibuebä hat er
den Innerschweizer Stil mitgeprägt.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Er ist auch eine Erscheinung:
Wenn man ihn sieht -
mit seinem Bart
und dem Schwyzerörgeli -,
ist das wie ein Bild.
Man sieht und hört das
und es stimmt einfach.
Es ist so authentisch,
ihn am Schwyzerörgeli zu sehen.
Für mich als Schwyzerörgeler
ist er eine Legende.
Das ist der "Waldstätten-Schottisch"
von Josef Stump.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Die grössten Koryphäen,
die ich ja nicht mehr kannte,
waren für mich Josef Stump
und Balz Schmidig.
Diese Musik ist zeitlos.
Ich fand es speziell,
dass sie von Marsch, Mazurka,
Polka, Ländler bis Walzer spielten.
Sie waren vielseitig.
Meistens hörte man
nur Ländler und Schottisch,
aber sie
spielten in allen Taktarten,
die für mich
auch zur Ländlermusik gehören.
Das faszinierte mich.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Die Volksmusik ist nicht verstaubt.
Alles, was in der Volksmusik lebt,
ist extrem lebendig.
Diese Musik besteht
und sie wird sicher
auch über die Zeit hinaus bestehen.
Es herrschen aber z.T.
sehr starre Strukturen -
v.a. im vokalen Bereich,
zu dem auch der "Jodelverband"
gehört.
Dort wäre es an der Zeit,
etwas zu ändern.
* Sanfter Jodelgesang *
Das Gender-Thema ist mittlerweile
auch in der Volksmusik präsent.
Und es ist wirklich so,
dass früher ganz allgemein
viele Zweige unserer Gesellschaft
von Männern dominiert wurden.
Das war in der Volksmusik
auf jeden Fall auch so.
In der instrumentalen Volksmusik
gab es immer wenig Frauen.
Am Anfang
waren sie v.a. in Begleitfunktionen.
Mal spielte eine Frau Bassgeige
oder mal spielte eine Klavier.
Bei der Umfrage fiel auf,
dass v.a. Männernamen fielen,
doch es gab auch Ausnahmen.
Ich habe immer Freude,
wenn auch Frauen mitspielen.
Wie bei der Kapelle Aregger.
Frau ...
Wie heisst sie schon wieder?
Meier.
- Frau Meier.
Ich möchte sagen,
dass in eine rassige Ländlerkapelle
eine Frau gehört -
sei es am Klavier oder am Bass.
Bei der Ländlerkapelle Aregger
spielt Frau Meier.
Darf ich vorstellen?
Das ist Frau Meier.
Sie spielte früher mit ihrem Vater,
dem berühmten Volksmusiker
Fritz Mosimann.
Seit 13 Jahren
ist sie bei der Kapelle Aregger.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Erst
in der relativ jungen Vergangenheit
konnten junge Frauen -
und Frauen allgemein -
alle Instrumente spielen,
wobei das Schwyzerörgeli
klar übervertreten ist.
In einer Kindervolksmusikwoche
oder einem Jungtalentschuppen
vom Haus der Volksmusik
sehen wir, dass die Geschlechter
sehr ausgeglichen verteilt sind.
Dann gibt es auch noch
den Eidgenössischen Jodlerverband.
Der heisst immer noch Jodlerverband,
auch im 21. Jh.
Dass der Jodlerverband
immer noch so heisst ...
Man könnte es einfach
auf "Jodelverband" ändern
und es wäre genderneutral.
* Sanfter Jodelgesang *
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass das Jodeln
aus der Männerchortradition stammt
und man es einfach
"Jodlerverband" nannte.
Es gab einfach viele Männerchöre.
Mit der Zeit kamen Frauen dazu,
als Vorjodlerinnen usw.
Und es wurde einfach nicht geändert.
Ich schreibe mittlerweile
einfach immer "Jodelverband".
Es wäre eine ganz kleine Änderung,
die man vornehmen müsste,
damit es gendergerecht wird.
Ich frage mich, warum man das
nicht schon lange gemacht hat.
Ich finde es
eine wichtige Diskussion,
aber für mich ist die Diskussion
über die Musik und den Inhalt
viel wichtiger.
Ich glaube,
das hat mit dieser Bubble zu tun.
In den Städten
ist es ein sehr wichtiges Thema.
Auf dem Land ist das
noch nicht wirklich angekommen.
Der zweite Grund ist auch,
dass es wohl über 90 % Männer sind.
Es sind relativ wenige Frauen
im Jodlerverband.
Der klassische Jodlerklub
ist eigentlich ein Männerchor -
mit einem oder zwei Solojodlern,
die dann wirklich jodeln.
Das sind oft Frauen.
Die Präsidentin ist auch eine Frau:
ein erster Schritt.
Aber sie wird sich
in den nächsten Jahren
kaum um die Namensänderung kümmern.
Ich komme
aus einer anderen Generation
und bin anders aufgewachsen.
Ich mache den Unterschied zwischen
Mann und Frau nicht so stark.
Wir arbeiteten immer zusammen,
daher fiel es mir nicht so auf,
bis ich in den Jodlerverband kam.
Es heisst immer noch
"Jodlerverband".
Auch beim Logo wäre es an der Zeit,
es mal - zusammen mit dem Namen -
zu überarbeiten,
damit es gerecht ist
und der heutigen Zeit entspricht.
Das ist aber nicht
die erste Priorität.
Wichtig ist ja,
was man im Herzen trägt
und wie man es
als Mitglied betrachtet.
Ich gebe aber zu,
dass wir gewisse Dinge anpacken
und überarbeiten müssen.
Ich glaube ganz fest daran,
dass Tradition offen sein
und Leute erreichen muss,
die nicht in dieser traditionellen
Umgebung aufgewachsen sind.
Nur so kann Tradition
über die Zeit auch bestehen.
Wir sind hier in Altdorf.
Ich probe im Moment mit Tout Bleu,
einer Genfer
Punk-Minimal-Noise-Band, whatever.
Wir kamen vor zwei Jahren
für ein Projekt
der Klangwelt Toggenburg zusammen.
Das Alpentöne-Festival lud uns ein,
um das wieder zu machen
und zusammen Patterns und Beats
zu suchen und Jodel darüberzulegen.
Und das machen wir jetzt.
* Rhythmische, elektronische Musik *
* Moderner Jodelgesang *
Der Volksmusikanteil dabei
ist die Jodeltechnik,
die ich hineinbringe.
Ja, das war's.
* Sanfter Jodelgesang *
Simone nahm bei mir Jodelunterricht.
Sie studierte an der Hochschule
Luzern klassischen Gesang.
Sie hat Verbindungen zur Volksmusik,
aber ihr Ding
war die klassische Musik.
Sie hatte aber immer eine Affinität.
Über die Schule durfte sie
nicht jodeln, also kam sie privat.
An ihrem Diplom jodelte sie dann
einen Teil ihres Programms.
* Sanfter Jodelgesang *
* Moderner Jodelgesang *
Ich finde es extrem spannend,
über Grenzen hinauszugehen
und zu schauen, was man machen kann.
Natürlich geht man das Risiko ein,
gegen eine Wand zu laufen,
aber nur so findet man heraus,
wo man weitergehen kann,
und wie man zu dem,
was man kann, zurückkommt.
# Öpper het öppe es Märli verzellt,
# vo Helde und Gränze,
wos z'ehre git.
# Öpper hets gseit,
und öpper hets glaubt.
# Und öpper hets schnell
i d'Gschicht inebout.
# So schichte mir Schichte
und Gschichte uf Gschicht,
# bis niemert meh weiss,
dass es es Märli gsi isch.
* Beschwingter Jodelgesang *
Schwingsport und Ländlermusik
gehören natürlich zusammen.
Das Alphorn darf auf
dem Schwingplatz auch nicht fehlen.
Meistens ist noch ein Jodelklub da.
Früher lief immer Ländlermusik -
sei es auf der Rigi, auf dem Stoos.
An allen Bergfesten
wurde Ländlermusik gespielt.
Ich hatte immer Freude am Schwingen.
Ich besuchte jedes Training
und holte schon jung einen Kranz.
Ich hatte aber Unfälle,
die mich etwas zurückwarfen.
Ich musste das Knie
und die Schulter operieren.
So musste ich mehr Orgel spielen,
was auch nicht schlecht war.
Ich hatte mit 20 die Gelegenheit,
Kontakt mit Nauer Martin senior
aufzunehmen,
der meine Lieblingsmusik spielte.
Ich durfte mit ihm spielen
und ihn Dinge fragen.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Ein Freund von Martin Nauer
war Hans Gwerder.
An einem lustigen Abend überredete
er mich, nach Amerika mitzukommen.
Ich sagte zu,
was ich am nächsten Tag bereute.
Da sagte Brigitte: "Wenn du
zugesagt hast, musst du gehen."
Heute sind wir unterwegs
ans Schwingfest in Portland.
Das sind rund 2 1/2 Std. Fahrt.
Das war wirklich schön.
Ich war fünf Wochen dort,
an vier Schwingfesten.
Ich spielte Örgeli
und war auch noch am Schwingen.
Jetzt geht's weiter mit Turner-
schwinger Koni Gras und Lüönd Alois.
Der Mann mit den Hosenträgern,
der gerade gewinnt,
Lüönd Alois,
steht bis jetzt an der Spitze.
Und er wird es weiterhin
auch bleiben.
Rund 20 Schwinger
sind hier in Portland angetreten.
Und der Sieger heisst Lüönd Alois -
hier am ersten Kranzfest
in Amerika, in Portland.
Wir gratulieren
und mit einem herzlichen Dankeschön
verabschieden wir uns
vom Schwingplatz in Portland.
Der Sohn von Balz Schmidig
hatte noch eine Platte,
die ich nicht hatte.
Er liess sie laufen.
Das faszinierte mich so
und ich fragte mich,
was in aller Welt
sie da gemacht hatten.
Das könne doch nicht sein.
Später lernte ich das Stück auch.
Bei Wysel Gyr
konnten wir es dann aufnehmen -
in einer Fernsehsendung.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Es heisst auf der Platte
eigentlich "Muotathaler Marsch",
aber da es ein Ländler ist, nannten
wir es "Muotathaler Gäuerler".
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Jetzt sind wir in Chappelenwald,
Unterschönenbuch.
Natur und Volksmusik
sind eng miteinander verbunden.
In der Natur
wird man auch inspiriert.
Man hört etwas,
v.a., wenn das Vieh rausgelassen
wird und die Glocken läuten.
Im Wald ist es schön ruhig.
Da kann man abschalten.
Wenn man ein kleines Problem hat,
ist es nachher wieder gut.
Ich nehme nach und nach alles raus,
was umfällt.
Das ist auch besser fürs Wild.
Wir haben viele Hirsche -
das ist dann der Nachteil.
Aber die müssen ja auch etwas haben.
Dezember 2021 und das Dezember 2022.
Man schreibt jeweils an,
wann man holzte.
Das zu bewahren, wäre richtig.
Das Phänomen
gibt es nicht nur in den Städten,
sondern auch auf dem Land.
Man sieht ja, wie
die Agglomerationen grösser werden
und wie viele andere Einflüsse
es gibt.
Muotathal-Ybrig -
da sind die traditionellen Einflüsse
einfach grösser.
An den anderen Orten
nimmt es langsam überhand.
Da besteht die Gefahr,
dass man überfremdet wird.
Ich kann ein Beispiel nennen:
Wenn man örgelt,
haben viele kleine Kinder Freude.
Danach werden sie aber
mit fremdländischer Musik berieselt
und vergessen es.
Volksmusik sollte eigentlich
nicht politisch sein,
aber man pflegt noch eher
die alten Werte.
Gegenüber den neuen.
Die sind dann eher im linken Lager,
wir eher im rechten.
Aber man sollte mehr
zusammenarbeiten.
Einige können das,
aber die Linken heute
machen so viele Vorstösse,
die keinen Rappen nützen,
sondern den Bürgern nur schaden.
Das trifft auf einen gewissen Teil
der Ländlermusik zu.
Schweizer,
die traditionsbewusst sind,
die an Schwingfeste gehen
oder hornussen,
sind politisch
eher auf der rechten Seite.
Das liegt auch ein bisschen
in der Natur der Sache.
Das Ländliche, das Schweizverbundene
ist eher eine rechte Gesinnung,
sage ich jetzt mal,
ohne das jetzt
irgendwie werten zu wollen.
Rhythmisch und farbig machen
die Jungen auf sich aufmerksam.
Noch nie haben sich so viele
Jugendverbände zusammengetan.
500'000 Mitglieder zählen sie.
Unterstützt wird das Komitee
von Sängerin Christine Lauterburg.
* Kräftiger Gesang *
Für das Komitee geht es
beim Antirassismusgesetz darum,
die Menschenwürde aller Bewohner
der Schweiz zu garantieren.
Ein Gesetz, das für Respekt wirbt.
Ich habe schon den Eindruck,
dass es einfach
zu wenig Respekt gibt.
Am Anfang
wollte niemand mit mir jodeln:
"Uh, Volksmusik!"
"Bist du bei der SVP?"
Da sagte ich mir:
"Blasius, ich mache es selber,
wenn ihr alle schon von Anfang an
Angst davor habt."
Am 2. März war Wahlsonntag
in der Stadt Zürich.
Die SVP feierte.
Die Schweizerische Volkspartei
ist die bodenständigste
der Bundesratsparteien.
Die Stadtzürcher
politisieren gar am rechten Flügel.
Es ist ja naheliegend,
dass Parteien wie die SVP,
die sich wirklich auf die Heimat
und das eigene Land beziehen,
Volksmusik um sich scharen.
Da geht es ja genau auch um Heimat
und die eigene Scholle.
Das ist total logisch.
Diese Konnotation kommt wohl noch
aus den 70er-, 80er-, 90er-Jahren.
(Brülisauer) Es ist auffällig,
dass auch politische Parteien,
die eher rechts stehen,
sich sehr gerne mit Tradition
und Heimat dekorieren.
Da gehört halt auch Volksmusik dazu.
Die instrumentale Volksmusik
ist grundsätzlich unpolitisch.
Wie es
mit der gesungenen aussieht ...
# Die Herzen auf, die Rosen blüh'n.
Da sind allenfalls
gewisse Textpassagen
aus heutiger Sicht eher konservativ.
Aber auch dort werden nicht explizit
politische Botschaften
transportiert.
Das möchte ich
schon sehr relativieren.
Heute kämpfen
gewisse Trychlergruppen
gegen die Coronamassnahmen.
Gegenüber der Sendung "Rundschau"
wollten sie kein Interview geben.
Ja ...
Von aussen verbindet man die Musik
vielleicht schon indirekt
mit der Politik:
"Die Ländlermusikanten
sind doch SVP."
"Und die Trychler sowieso."
Aber ich weiss,
dass dieses Klischee nicht stimmt.
Ich kenne viele, die offen sind,
aber den Brauch ausüben.
Klar, durch die Freiheitstrychler
kam das Klischee
von einer politischen Haltung
leider etwas auf.
Aber deswegen geht unser Brauchtum
hier genau gleich weiter.
Irgendwann gibt es
die Freiheitstrychler nicht mehr,
unser Brauchtum aber schon.
Diese Leute haben verschiedene
politische Einstellungen.
Ich finde,
das sollte man nicht vergleichen.
Ich finde es schade,
dass es sofort
damit in Verbindung gebracht wird,
bevor man sich ein Bild über die
Leute und ihre Einstellung macht.
Oft sind die Leute offener,
als man von aussen vielleicht denkt.
Immer, wenn es eine Krise gibt,
versucht man,
sich als Land zu einen.
Kultur ist dann Kunst.
Das wird instrumentalisiert,
damit ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl
entsteht.
Seit ...
Ja, seit Leute wie Dani
oder Markus kamen,
hat sich das wieder
ein bisschen geöffnet.
Dadurch kommt es wieder etwas weg
von der politischen Rechten.
Volksmusik ist grundsätzlich ...
... von der traditionellen Seite aus
betrachtet, eher rechts.
Wenn man die Neue Volksmusik
ansieht, ist sie eher links.
Der grösste Teil
tummelt sich wohl in der Mitte.
Ich finde es ein schwieriges Thema.
Ich glaube,
es ist weniger ein rechtes Denken -
das ist ohnehin negativ behaftet -,
sondern eher
das konservative Denken.
Das trifft es eher,
aber auch nur sehr bedingt.
In meinen Kreisen
ist es überhaupt nicht so.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass es abhängig vom Musikgenre ist.
Ich glaube, das konservative Denken
gibt es in allen Musikgenres.
Auch die,
die sehr offen sein wollen,
sind es manchmal gar nicht.
(Felber) Anfänglich hinterfragte ich
die Jodellieder nicht gross.
Das ist auch gut, denn es gibt
so viele schöne Jodellieder.
Irgendwann merkte ich, dass es schon
sehr oft um ein "Meiteli" geht.
Die Frauen werden sehr oft
in eine objektivizierte Rolle
hineingepresst,
was gar nicht zu mir passt.
Ich bin auch nicht mit
meinem ersten Schätzeli zusammen.
Gegen diese Stereotype vom
"liebe Meiteli" und "guete Müeti"
singt nun der erste feministische
Jodelchor der Schweiz an.
Die Truppe namens Echo vom Eierstock
nimmt sich witzig-pointiert
dem traditionellen Liedgut an
und interpretiert es progressiv neu.
# Mir sind s'Echo vom Eierstock,
# träged auch e churze Rock.
# Und ab und zu
hemmer halt eifach kei Bock.
Mit dem Echo vom Eierstock
haben wir v.a. das Ziel,
dass wir Jodellieder
von Sexismus befreien.
In vielen Jodelliedern
werden Frauenfiguren
sehr stark objektiviziert
oder auch mit sehr viel
Verniedlichungen beschrieben.
Es sind nie starke,
emanzipierte Frauen.
# Immer wenn i wieder
z'wenig Lohn überchum,
# wehri mi und bliib nit stumm.
# Wenn i wieder z'wenig Lohn
überchum, bliib i nit stumm.
Echo vom Eierstock ist mir
selbstverständlich ein Begriff.
Ich kann es sehr gut nachvollziehen,
dass man auf die Idee kam,
einen solchen Chor zu gründen,
weil es eine Tatsache ist,
dass sich viele Texte
von Jodelliedern
sehr um eine heile Alpenwelt
und eher ältere
gesellschaftliche Normen drehen.
Sie gehen politisch bewusst
in eine andere Richtung.
Sie thematisieren auch
das Frauenthema.
Das ist genau das,
was in der Volksmusik fehlt:
es griffig auf den Punkt zu bringen
und neues Publikum zu erschliessen.
Ich finde es super,
was Simone Felber macht,
aber der Chor ist grottenschlecht.
Das bestreitet sie auch nicht.
Es ist ein Laienchor
mit Anfängerinnen.
Sie können natürlich nicht
mit Leuten mithalten,
die das seit 10, 20 Jahren
üben und praktizieren.
Aber ich finde es durchaus
eine Chance.
Gerade im Jodellied sind die Texte
ziemlich aus der Zeit gefallen.
Die waren schon in den 30er-Jahren,
als sie entstanden,
schon ziemlich
aus der Zeit gefallen.
Es war damals schon Retro-Kitsch.
Das motiviert einfach nicht mehr
zum Singen.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Als Dirigentin
des Echo vom Eierstock
habe ich mich
natürlich stark exponiert.
Mir ist bewusst,
dass ich so eine Rolle einnehme
und Leute Dinge interpretieren.
Ich würde mir einfach wünschen,
dass viel mehr Leute
auf mich zukämen
und das Gespräch suchten.
Ich spüre die Blicke
und eine gewisse Abneigungen,
aber es kam noch nie
jemand auf mich zu:
"Was du machst,
finde ich nicht gut."
Ich würde gerne mal
mit so jemandem sprechen.
Argumente oder Beleidigungen
hatte ich v.a. in meinem Postfach,
aber niemand traute sich,
es persönlich zu sagen.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass Volksmusik
in den letzten Jahren
stark von rechten Parteien
beschlagnahmt wurde.
Ich finde es aber ganz wichtig,
dass man die Volksmusik
wieder von dort wegbringt.
Volksmusik ist nichts Politisches,
es gehört allen.
Um dahinzukommen,
sind wir noch nicht am Punkt.
Mit dem Echo vom Eierstock z.B.
haben wir uns quasi
in die andere Ecke gestellt.
Jetzt gibt es die beiden Fronten
und man muss schauen, was, wie, wo.
Und ich hoffe,
dass sich das irgendwann -
vielleicht in einigen Generationen -
beginnt aufzuweichen
und man miteinander redet.
Das Schöne an der Volksmusikszene
ist,
dass alles toll ist
und Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen
herrscht.
Nein, es sind alles Menschen.
Ich glaube aber trotzdem,
dass die Bodenständigkeit,
die die Volksmusikszene
mit sich bringt,
vieles einfacher macht.
# Wie dunkt eim mängisch öisi Zyt
so lieblos, trüeb u läär.
Durch die Medien wird schon noch oft
die heile Welt in der Volksmusik
vermittelt.
Heile Welt ...
Das gibt es heute ja kaum noch.
Ist es schlecht?
Wenn das Wetter schön ist, die
Gegend schön ist - ist das schlecht?
Oder setzt das noch einmal
den Klischee-Stempel drauf?
Das Klischee der schönen heilen Welt
wurde auf jeden Fall zelebriert.
Das Klischee der heilen Welt
wurde durchaus gepflegt.
Ich denke,
auch heute noch ein bisschen.
Ich nervte mich darüber.
Die Medien haben eine wichtige Rolle
in der Darstellung der Volksmusik.
Meistens sind Menschen
nicht mehr so natürlich,
wenn man eine Kamera auf sie hält.
Für uns ist wichtig, Volksmusik
möglichst authentisch abzubilden.
Bei allen Themen
haben die Medien eine grosse Kraft.
Das hat einen grossen Einfluss,
wie über ein Musikgenre,
z.B. Volksmusik, gedacht wird.
# Mer suecht halt meischtens
nur viu z'wyt.
# Nimm doch nit alls so schwäär.
# Drum los, was i dir z'säge ha.
* Sanfte Alphornklänge *
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
(Wyss) Es gibt verschiedene Arten
von Sendungen.
Gehen wir an ein Volksmusikfest,
sehen wir uns das Line-up an -
wer dort spielt und wann,
und welche Formationen wir
nacheinander bringen können,
damit die Sendung Sinn ergibt
und Freude bereitet.
Das Appenzeller Ländlerfest
ist perfekt dafür,
da so viele gute Formationen
spielen.
Das ist für uns
ein gefundenes Fressen,
da wir alles abbilden können,
was die Szene zu bieten hat.
Willkommen
am Appenzeller Ländlerfest.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
(Ringli) Ich finde es toll,
dass bei "Potzmusig"
wieder Livemusik gespielt wird.
Von der Auswahl her
ist es mir zu langweilig.
Der Durchschnitt wird präsentiert.
Man könnte es schweizerisch nennen.
Es ist nicht die Sendung,
die ich schaue,
um Dinge zu entdecken,
die ich noch nicht kannte.
Es hat auch noch Luft nach oben
in der ganzen Präsentation.
Es wirkt doch immer noch
ziemlich verkrampft.
Aber das ist ein grundsätzliches
Problem der Schweizer Volksmusik:
Die Livepräsentation ist -
vorsichtig gesagt -
nicht sehr lebhaft.
Das sehen wir in anderen
europäischen Ländern doch bewegter
und einfach mitreissender
und überzeugender.
Wir gehen weiter.
Da vorne wartet eine junge
Innerschweizer Formation mit
zehn Musikantinnen und Musikanten.
Wir schauen, was sie
Bodenständiges bereithalten -
nach einer Idee von Angela Gisler.
(Wyss) Wir versuchen in der Sendung,
die Szene so abzubilden,
wie sie ist.
Die Sendung verändert sich.
Als wir vor zehn Jahren anfingen,
sah sie noch anders aus.
Und sie wird sich weiterhin
verändern.
Es ist auch schön,
dass die Szene so vielseitig ist.
Es ist auch für uns
musikalisch einfach,
in einer Sendung
verschiedene Stile zu zeigen.
Manchmal ist es auch ein Problem,
da sich die Volksmusik
und die Geschmäcke auch verändern.
Das Publikum gewöhnt sich
an eine bestimmte Volksmusik
und dann kommen plötzlich Junge,
die neue Wege suchen.
Unsere Aufgabe ist auch,
diese Vielfalt zu zeigen.
Es ist auch wichtig,
dass wir unsere Fühler ausstrecken
und nicht nur von dem ausgehen,
das wir kennen.
Feste wie das Appenzeller Ländler-
fest können eine Inspiration sein,
wenn 5 % davon Formationen sind,
die noch nie in der Sendung waren.
Das sind immer wieder Hinweise,
um Neues zu entdecken.
(Wyss) In den 70er-, 80er-Jahren,
als das Schweizer Fernsehen
die einzige Möglichkeit war,
sich schweizweit zu verbreiten,
war man nach einem Auftritt
dann im Land auch bekannt.
Mit Social Media, Internet,
allen Möglichkeiten,
sich zu präsentieren,
hat es schon an Relevanz verloren,
aber die meisten Formationen
schätzen einen Auftritt trotzdem,
da man dann wie dazugehört
und Teil der Volksmusikfamilie ist.
Und es sind doch noch viele,
die die Sendung schauen.
Wir sind
ein fünfköpfiges Forschungsteam
unter der Leitung
von Prof. Dr. Bernhard Tschofen.
In unserem Projekt untersuchen wir
die Sendungssammlung des SRF.
Die Sendungen
entstanden zwischen 1960 und 1990 -
innerhalb der Redaktion
"Folklore und Heimat",
die damals von Wysel Gyr,
der selber als Moderator auftrat,
konzipiert und redigiert wurden.
Grüezi, liebe Zuschauer.
Unsere heutige Sendung wird v.a.
den Ländler- und Volksmusikfreuden
viel Freude bereiten.
Die überragende Forschungsfrage
unseres Projekts lautet:
Inwiefern hat das Fernsehen
die Volksmusikszene geprägt?
Mit ihrer Inszenierung,
der Darstellungen,
der gezeigten Bilder
wie die Musiker zum Spielen
in die Landschaft gesetzt wurden.
* Beschwingte Blasmusik *
Es ist wichtig zu erwähnen,
dass die 60er- bis 90er-Jahre
für die Schweizer Volksmusik
ein wichtiges Kapitel sind,
da sehr viel passierte -
auch durch das Medium Fernsehen.
Haben wir nicht noch ein Beispiel
von expliziter Kritik
an der Inszenierung?
Dass es nur eine heile Welt zeigt,
die es gar nicht gibt.
(Jäggi) Wir haben im Archiv
Unterlagen gefunden,
die zeigen, dass Wysel Gyr
sich dessen bewusst war.
Er kannte die Kommentare
in öffentlichen Zeitschriften.
Es gibt eine Kritik
eines Wirtschaftsprofessors
an einer Sendung von 1979.
Herr Gyr, wir müssen losfahren.
Wenn der Bahnhofsvorstand das sagt,
stimmt das wohl.
Lustigerweise finden wir das
im Mäppchen gleich nebeneinander.
Die Postkarten-Schweiz -
Wysel Gyr klebte eine Postkarte auf,
"Sonnenaufgang auf dem Eggishorn".
2'926 m ü.M.
Dann haben wir den Aletschgletscher.
Genau das
finden wir auch in der Sendung.
Richten wir den Blick nach rechts,
fällt er auf den Aletschgletscher
und das Aletschhorn.
(Eggmann) Er schreibt:
"Haben Sie sich auch geärgert,
als Mitte Oktober Wysel Gyr
im Fernsehen
mit der Furka-Oberalp-Bahn
von Brig nach Disentis fuhr?"
"Fidel musiziert und gesungen -
wirklich alles sehr nett."
(Neukomm) Er schreibt auch,
dass die Leute so ärmlich seien.
"Dort ist es nämlich
gar nicht mehr so romantisch,
sondern ärmlich."
Es wurden Subventionen
für die Landwirtschaft eingeführt
und es gab Probleme mit Armut
und Abwanderung.
Diese Probleme
wurden nicht dargestellt.
Diese Kritik gab es immer,
aber darum
ging es in den Sendungen auch nicht.
Es war keine informative Sendung,
sondern es ging um Unterhaltung
und darum, den Leuten
ein gutes Gefühl zu vermitteln.
(Brülisauer)
Die Medien haben eine grosse Rolle,
wie sie Volksmusik darstellen.
Also wie ich auf der Bank
auf der grünen Wiese
vielleicht
in der idyllischen Alpenwelt sitze.
Aber nur darum spielt Volksmusik
sich nicht in diesem Bereich ab.
Wenn Medien etwas so darstellen,
sind die besten,
die gängigsten Klischees bedient.
Die entsprechen halt
nicht immer der Realität.
Es ist an der Zeit,
dass man in der Volksmusik
auch urbane Menschen sieht.
Man hat immer das Postkartenbild
des Fahnenschwingers
und zwei Frauen in Trachten daneben.
Das aufzubrechen,
finde ich extrem spannend.
Ich weiss nicht, warum es
eine Schweizer Eigenart ist,
dass wir keine depressive Volksmusik
haben.
Volksmusik war in der Schweiz
immer Festmusik.
Da wollte man feiern und
die Sorgen des Alltags vergessen.
Volksmusik
hat etwas sehr Konstruktives.
Man versucht, Dinge aufzubauen,
und nicht immer nur zu sagen,
was schlecht ist.
Aber die permanente Fröhlichkeit
kann einem auf die Nerven gehen.
* Jauchzer *
Ich muss Ihnen nicht sagen,
dass auf der Heubühne in Rapperswil
eine ausgezeichnete Stimmung
herrscht.
Wir hoffen, dass die gute Laune
Sie zu Hause ansteckt.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen,
dass Sie auch mitsingen möchten.
Wir haben eine kleine Hilfe
für Sie bereit.
Das Klischee der schönen heilen Welt
wurde natürlich zelebriert.
Was gibt es Schöneres,
als Leute glücklich zu machen?
Man muss einfach spielen lassen
und die heile Welt
für eine Stunde zelebrieren.
# In Barcelona git's kei Schi,
drum fahred mir det gar nöd hi
# und blibed lieber grad dihei.
Solche Sendungen
haben nie so viele Zuschauer
und kommen nie so gut an,
wenn es den Leuten gut geht.
Wenn es den Leuten sehr gut geht,
geht das auseinander - sehr stark.
Aber wenn es den Leuten
schlecht geht,
kann man das zelebrieren.
Dazu stehe ich noch heute.
Ich blendete das aus und wollte
den Leuten eine Freude bereiten.
# S'isch gar nöd schwer,
chum, probier's doch emal.
# En Schwung nach rächts,
en Schwung nach links,
# das chönd dini Schi von elei.
Meine verehrte Jodlergemeinde:
Ist euer Tun zeitgemäss?
Die frohen Jodellieder -
sind sie mehr
als altes, schönes Brauchtum,
um uns
für ein paar unbeschwerte Stunden
eine friedliche,
eine heile Welt vorzutäuschen?
* Gefühlvoller Jodelgesang *
(Räss) Es gibt viele Lieder,
die die heile Welt,
die schönen Berge,
die Blumenpracht beschreiben.
Das hat verschiedene Gründe.
Es ist auch wirklich schön,
das lässt sich nicht negieren.
Ausserdem wurde das
im und Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs
vom Bundesrat
auch wirklich gefördert.
Es gibt sogar ein Dankesschreiben
an den Jodlerverband,
in dem es hiess, es sei gut,
dass sie die Identität
auch musikalisch stärken.
Viele Leute
haben aber Mühe mit der heilen Welt,
weil es nicht immer so ist.
Ich nervte mich darüber.
Inzwischen nicht mehr.
Denn man kann sich entweder
mit der Welt auseinandersetzen
und immer ganz viel Schlechtes
sehen,
oder man kann die Musik einfach
als Oase der Zufriedenheit sehen.
"Ich mag es gemütlich."
Früher
arbeitete man den ganzen Tag hart,
danach konnte man sich der Musik,
dem Schönen, widmen.
Das soll ja auch so sein.
Ich finde aber,
dass man auch in der Volksmusik
das Unschöne adressieren muss,
und dafür stehe ich.
# Öpper seit,
s'sigi genau so passiert.
# Und öpper hets Ändi
z'ändere probiert.
# Und öpper vermischts
mitere andere Gschicht.
# Und öpper verschpricht sich
und öpper vergisst.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
(Frick) Wenn man am Zauern ist
und die Emotionen weckt -
gerade an Silvester -,
kann man die Leute etwas beobachten.
Man sieht, wie manchen
doch eine Träne hinunterläuft.
Es ist alles andere als fröhlich -
und das ist vielleicht das Problem:
dass unsere Medien
auch nicht die urchige,
die echte, die wilde Musik bringen,
sondern immer den geblümten Trog.
Cyrill Schläpfer
veröffentlichte eine schöne CD.
Dort hört man wirklich Sennen,
die während des Melkens
rau einen Jutz singen.
* Melancholisches Jutzen *
Das ist nur auf so einer CD
zu finden, nie im Fernsehen.
# Schibel, schabel, schübel,
d'Milch, die muess in Chübel.
# Ai wanna bii milking yuu,
just yuu.
# Jetzt heb doch still, du Chue.
# Mir si Oesch's die Dritte
vom Stalde.
# Hei de Plausch a dr Musig u singe.
# Das isch öppis,
wo d'ihr müesst probiere,
# denn ihr chöit euri Sorge verliere.
Das Klischee ist da,
aber es gibt noch viel mehr.
Es ist, wie wenn man eine Massage
bucht oder ins Wellnesshotel geht.
Es ist vergleichbar.
Man will sich etwas Gutes tun.
# ... allne Lüt.
# Mit dr Hand
isch dr Gruess vo Bedütig.
Wir leben in einem 500-Seelen-Dorf.
Wenn man am Morgen die Tür öffnet,
hört man die Vögel pfeifen
und die Kuhglocken.
Das ist kein Witz, das ist dort so.
Wir sehen die Stockhornkette
weiss verschneit
und unten die Blumenwiese.
- Ohne Nebel.
Meistens, ja.
Es ist einfach so.
Wir haben extrem Glück,
in so einem schönen Land zu leben -
mit so gutem Essen
und so grosser Vielfalt.
Wir wollen euch an diesem Gefühl
des Gutgehens teilhaben lassen.
* Rasanter Jodelgesang *
Juhu!
Unter dem Titel "Hilfswerk
für die Kinder der Landstrasse"
nahm Pro Juventute
zwischen 1926 und 1973
über 600 Kinder ihren Familien weg,
steckte sie in Heime
oder brachte sie
bei Pflegeeltern unter.
Wir machten schlimme Dinge durch.
Wirklich schlimme Dinge.
Wir wurden behandelt
wie der letzte Dreck.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
(Brülisauer) Der jenische Einfluss
ist im Moment in aller Munde -
auch völlig zu Recht.
Denn die Geschichte der Jenischen
in der Schweiz
ist immer noch
ziemlich schlecht erforscht.
In Bezug auf die Musik
gibt es unbestritten
einen Einfluss der Jenischen.
Gerade zu Beginn der Volksmusik
oder der Ländlermusik,
also anfangs 20. Jh.
und natürlich auch im 19. Jh.,
machten viele fahrende Musikanten
solche Musik.
Natürlich haben sie
musikalisches Kulturerbe
in diese Musik eingebracht.
Es sind bis heute Spuren zu finden.
Aber ich möchte das nicht
als allzu wichtig
und zu stilprägend einordnen -
im Unterschied zu anderen Leuten,
die sich mit der Materie befassen.
V.a. kann man nicht sagen,
dass es die heutige Volksmusik
nur wegen der jenischen Musikanten
gibt.
Es gibt sie a u c h
wegen der jenischen Musikanten.
Bei der Frage um die Jenischen
ist der ganze Skandal nicht,
ob jemand jemandem Musik geklaut hat
oder ob es
kulturelle Aneignung gibt,
sondern wie mit ihnen in Hunderten
von Jahren umgegangen wurde.
Fast 50 Jahre lang
wurden auf Initiative
einer karitativen Institution
Familien auseinandergerissen
und Kinder den Eltern
illegal weggenommen.
Das ist eine traurige Geschichte.
Ich war drei Jahre
von meinen Eltern getrennt.
Mein Bruder später auch.
Ich war der Älteste.
Das war eine schlimme Sache.
Das sind Geschichten, die bleiben.
Die verschwinden nicht mehr.
Ich kriegte Schläge von den Bauern.
Sie wollten meinen Namen ändern.
"Du heisst nicht mehr Mülhauser."
"Du musst krampfen
und das Melken erlernen."
Tat man es nicht,
kriegte man Schläge.
Das ist unsere liebe Schweiz.
Das ganze Thema
mit den Kindern der Landstrasse ...
Aus heutiger Sicht
war das sicher ein Verbrechen.
Es ist eine Ausrottung.
Was ich mitmachte,
kann man gar nicht schildern.
Ich musste den Wohnwagen verkaufen
und mir ein Zelt anschaffen,
damit ich mich im Wald
verstecken konnte.
Ich kam mir vor
wie eine Schwerverbrecherin.
Mitten in der Nacht
musste ich weinen,
weil die Polizei kontrollierte
und mir das Kind wegnehmen wollte.
(Brülisauer) Das Ziel war,
die Herumreisenden,
die "Vaganten", wie man auch sagte,
die "Zigeuner" sesshaft zu machen -
und zwar durch Zwang.
Das tut man am effizientesten,
indem man bei den Jungen anfängt,
sodass die gar nicht wissen,
wie die eigene Kultur funktioniert,
wenn sie das Nomadisieren
gar nicht kennenlernen.
Sie wollten uns anpassen an -
ich sage jetzt nicht "normal" -
die Idiotengesellschaft.
Entschuldigung.
Ja ...
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Die Ländlermusik war immer gut.
Daran kann ich nichts kritisieren.
Ich sage immer: Musik weltweit
hat nichts mit Politik zu tun.
Das ist das Schöne.
Die jenischen Familien
haben eine Ländlermusiktradition.
Ich spiele einen Teil so,
den zweiten auf meine Art.
Ich mache immer mein Ding.
Das sind zwei verschiedene Arten
von Musik:
Zigeunermusik und Ländlermusik.
Aber ich mache nie
einen Abend lang Zigeunermusik.
Ich bringe immer Ländlermusik
mit rein.
Oder einen Schottisch.
Das gehört bei mir dazu.
Das sind meine Wurzeln,
aber auf meine Art.
Voilà.
Wir gehen jetzt
in ein Zigeuner-Kultur-Zentrum.
Hier spiele ich heute Abend.
Hier gibt es ein Festzelt.
Das machen sie jedes Jahr.
Sali.
Beginnen wir mit dem Ländler?
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Grüezi,
liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer.
In der heutigen Sendung "Öisi Musig"
kann ich Ihnen eine ganze Reihe
exklusiver und vielleicht
auch ausgefalleneren musikalischen
Delikatessen offerieren.
Rolf Wyss, das war ein Chefredaktor
des Schweizer Fernsehens,
von Wysel Gyr.
Der rief mich an und fragte mich,
ob er eine Sendung
mit unserer Musik machen dürfe.
Ich war mit meinem Bruder
mit dem Wohnwagen in Basel.
Dann kamen sie und filmten uns.
Sie filmten uns
beim Fahren mit dem Wohnwagen
bis nach Sursee zum Zirkusplatz.
Danach kam Rolf Wyss zu mir
und meinte, sie hätten Probleme.
Sie hätten
eine Bewilligung gekriegt,
aber die sei nun entzogen worden.
Sie sagten Ja.
Als sie merkten, dass wir
Jenische sind, hiess es Nein.
Wir blieben trotzdem.
Das SRF konnte das regeln.
Wir durften in Sursee
einen Besuch machen.
Ich möchte noch einmal
der Bevölkerung von hier danken,
dass wir hier auf dem Zirkusplatz
neben dem Fussballplatz
diese Sendung realisieren durften.
Ich möchte aber
im gleichen Atemzug sagen,
dass es ein Zirkusplatz bleibt
und er auch in Zukunft
nicht für andere Fahrende
offensteht.
Wenn wir uns vorstellen, dass es
diese Sendungen nicht gegeben hätte
und im Fernsehen
nie Volksmusik gezeigt worden wäre:
Wie würde es dann aussehen?
Das ist eine schwierige Frage.
(Neukomm)
Wysel Gyr war schon eine Instanz.
Mit ihm konnte man sich im Fernsehen
in Szene setzen.
Und als Chef der Redaktion
war er in der Position,
zu entscheiden,
wer in seinen Sendungen vorkam
und wer eben nicht.
Was uns aber alle aus der Musikszene
sagen, ist,
dass er
sehr hohe Qualitätsansprüche hatte.
Ein bekannter Akkordeonist
aus dem Toggenburg: Willi Valotti.
* Ruhige Ländlermusik *
Gyr war halt ...
Ich sage es jetzt mal ...
Das ist vielleicht etwas böse,
aber er bestimmte einfach.
Er bestimmte, was er wollte -
von den Protagonisten, die er holte.
Da durfte ihm niemand reinreden.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Wysel Gyr
war eine zwiespältige Figur.
Einerseits war er sehr wichtig
für die Volksmusik,
da er sie ins Fernsehen brachte.
Er machte wunderbare Produktionen,
nahm Livemusik auf.
Der Nachteil war, dass er
strikte Vorstellungen davon hatte,
was Volksmusik ist und was nicht.
So stärkte er eher
die konservative Richtung.
Insofern trug er sehr stark
zu dieser Bewahrungsmentalität bei.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Wysel war natürlich
ein Traditionalist.
Ganz eindeutig.
Das vertrat er auch.
Eine Zeit lang musste man sogar
in der Tracht auftreten.
Das war Vorschrift.
Ohne Tracht
durfte man nicht in die Sendung.
Man stelle sich das heute mal vor!
Ich war eher auf der anderen Seite.
# Ai, ai, ai, Musica.
- Hallo, hallo, hallo.
Diese zwei Lager gab es.
Später ging es dann auch
um volkstümliche Unterhaltung.
Am Anfang verteufelte man mich,
das war so.
# Oh läck du mir, oh läck du mir,
oh läck du mir am Tschöpli.
"Jetzt kommt da einer,
der noch Jodler ist,
und geht
an den Grand Prix der Volksmusik!"
"Das hat doch nichts
mit Volksmusik zu tun."
Den Leuten
gefiel das unglaublich gut.
Und ich glaube, dass Sepp Trütsch
die Unterhaltung
in die Volksmusik brachte
und das sehr populär machte.
* Ruhiger Jodelgesang *
Ein schöner Jodel,
der sicher allen gefällt.
Ich durfte die musikalischen Signets
einspielen.
Da wollte man volkstümlichen
Schlager auf die Schippe nehmen.
Heute finde ich das eher peinlich.
Aber ich erinnere mich
trotzdem gerne daran.
Es ist schon ernst gemeint.
Jeder von uns möchte Geld verdienen.
Die Sendung hatte ja die Absicht,
Dinge auf die Schippe zu nehmen.
Das störte mich überhaupt nicht.
Da konnte man ausrufen, wie man
wollte, das beflügelte es nur.
Einen schönen guten Abend,
liebe Gäste
und liebe Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer zu Hause bei "Fyraabig".
Es freut mich,
dass wir auch heute mit "Fyraabig"
bei Ihnen zu Hause Gast sein dürfen.
Wir hatten ja
gewaltige Einschaltquoten.
Als wir zum ersten Mal
über eine Million hatten,
fragte mich der damalige Direktor,
was ich gemacht hätte.
Dann sagte ich: "Schau die Sendung,
dann weisst du es auch."
Das war natürlich
eine ganz andere Zeit.
Es ist ein Megaprivileg,
Volksmusiksendungen zu produzieren.
Das Wichtigste ist, die Volksmusik
möglichst authentisch abzubilden.
Meistens erlebt man das,
wenn irgendwo jemand spielt
und alle fröhlich sind.
Sobald man mit der Kamera kommt,
kommt eine Anspannung auf.
"Wir müssen jetzt das spielen,
das funktioniert."
"Wir wollen genau das zeigen."
Dann verliert es an Authentizität.
Dieses Problem gab es schon früher.
Man versuchte es zu lösen,
z.B. mit Play-back
oder indem man alle anwies
zu lachen.
Einige taten das,
andere fanden es sehr doof.
* Rasante Ländlermusik *
Wir sind konzentriert,
wenn wir spielen.
Am Fernsehen
kam je länger je mehr das Thema auf,
dass die Leute ja
in den Bildschirm schauen
und nicht einfach
vier Köpfe sehen wollen,
die sich stur
auf das Stück konzentrieren,
das sie gerade spielen.
Dann musste man anfangen zu lächeln
und zu schaukeln und weiss ich was.
Dann hiess es,
wenn man noch Show machen muss,
kann man nicht noch
ein schwieriges Stück spielen.
Dann muss es Play-back sein.
Dann kann man schon etwas schaukeln
und machen.
Ich war eigentlich dagegen.
Dann kam das Play-back
und der Regisseur -
ganz ein lieber aus Basel - meinte,
wir müssten beim Reinkommen
spielend durch das Publikum gehen.
Als ich vorne war,
hörte ich auf zu spielen
und schüttelte
links und rechts die Hände.
Das kam dann etwas schräg rüber.
Ja, in der Musikszene gab es Leute,
die meinten,
es sei Valotti endgültig
in den Kopf gestiegen,
wenn er am Fernsehen
solchen Mist macht.
Ja ... Andere fanden es lustig.
Die Play-back-Phase in den Medien
war wohl die Phase,
in denen die Medien nicht wussten,
was sie an der Volksmusik haben.
Da wollte man zuerst einmal,
dass die Quoten stimmten.
Volksmusik ist eine Musik,
die in den allermeisten Fällen
nicht mit Perfektion funktioniert,
sondern sie funktioniert
eigentlich in der Situation,
in der sie stattfindet.
Es ist vielfach
eine Tanzveranstaltung,
wo das Publikum eben auch mitmacht
und am ganzen Ambiente
beteiligt ist.
Wohin sich die Szene bewegt,
liegt nicht an mir,
nicht am Fernsehen
und auch nicht an der Szene.
Es ist eine organische Entwicklung
in irgendeine Richtung,
die auf uns einklingen wird.
Die Zukunft ...
Es wäre schade, wenn die alten
Stücke beiseitegeschoben würden.
Es ist alles auf gutem Weg.
Ich habe keine Wünsche,
was in 20 Jahren sein soll.
Es gibt ganz tolle Talente,
und es ist wichtig,
dass die in guten Händen sind.
Sie machen es sehr gut.
Ich habe wirklich Freude
an den jungen Cracks.
Ich habe eine Vision,
nämlich,
dass die Schweizer Volksmusik
als junge, lebendige und
attraktive Szene wahrgenommen wird.
Die Jungen müssen das erleben.
- Da kommt in Zukunft
einiges Spannendes auf uns zu
vonseiten der Schweizer Volksmusik.
* Lebhafte Streichmusik *
Die Zukunft der Volksmusik?
Am wichtigsten ist,
dass man sicherstellt,
dass viele Leute eine Verbindung
zur Volksmusik haben.
Bei uns funktionierte es einfach.
Die Kinder waren klein
und hörten mich üben.
Ich glaube, sie merkten gut,
worum es ging.
Sie kriegten auch Freude daran.
* Kirchenglocke *
Das wäre das Wichtigste:
dass an allen Orten Leute sind,
die Volksmusik machen,
damit andere das hören
und auch Freude daran kriegen.
Grüezi, liebe Zuschauer.
in der heutigen Sendung
stellen wir Ihnen Klarinettist,
Kapellmeister und Dirigent
Domenic Janett vor.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Domenic ist mein Onkel.
Er ist natürlich einer
unserer Säulenheiligen der Fränzlis.
Was soll ich sagen?
Ich würde ihn auch
in die Legendenecke stellen.
Wir, als die Generation nach ihm,
verklären auch ein wenig die Zeiten,
in denen Domenic und seine Brüder
in Tschlin Tanzmusik machten.
Für uns ist das die goldene Zeit.
Aber wahrscheinlich
war sie auch nicht so golden.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Matinadas hiess das Ensemble,
das wir gerade gehört haben.
Es spielten die vier Gebrüder Janett
mit Flurin Caviezel.
Domenic Janett, dieses Stück
hat einen romanischen Titel.
"Furmias aint il chül".
- Was heisst das?
"Ameisen im Hintern".
Wenn ich zurückdenke,
als ich als Musiklehrer arbeitete -
ich mache ja gerne Volksmusik.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
meine Schüler
interessierten sich gar nicht dafür.
Was ich als Fehler
bezeichnen würde ...
Ich hätte vielleicht immer wieder
mit den Schülern
Volksmusikstücke spielen müssen.
Hätte man nach dreimal gemerkt,
dass sie nicht darauf eingehen,
hätte man die halt verloren.
Aber ich hatte das Gefühl,
das passe ihnen nicht.
Und ich bin nicht der Typ,
der für etwas wirklich enorm kämpft.
Komischerweise kam es dann so,
dass in den letzten Jahren,
in denen ich unterrichtete,
plötzlich alle Schüler Stücke aus
meinem Kompositionsbuch spielten.
Dann dachte ich, dass ich das
vor 20 Jahren hätte tun sollen.
* Lebhafte Musik *
Dass Schüler bei der Auswahl
nicht auf die Klarinette kommen,
liegt vielleicht gar nicht
an der Schwierigkeit.
Beim Auswählen wissen sie ja nicht,
ob etwas schwierig ist.
Es gibt viele Klarinettenlehrer,
die meinen,
sie hätten fast nur Saxofonschüler.
Warum das so ist,
weiss ich auch nicht.
Interessanterweise lernt jemand,
der Klarinette spielt,
ziemlich schnell Saxofon.
Umgekehrt
ist es ein bisschen schwieriger.
* Beschwingte Klarinettenmusik *
Am liebsten hätte ich es,
wenn sich das Ganze
so entwickeln würde,
dass in allen Regionen junge Leute
mehr Freude an der Volksmusik haben
als bis jetzt.
Das Rezept, um das zu erreichen,
kenne ich nicht so genau.
* Gemächliche Musik *
(Häusler)
Was den Nachwuchs betrifft,
steht es nicht so ideal,
gerade was Bläser angeht -
Klarinette, Saxofon -,
wenn man Musikschulen anschaut,
bei Holzbläsern schlechthin.
Blech schafft es etwas besser.
Im Moment ist es vielleicht
einfach nicht cool.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Gründe sind sicher, dass sie in
der Wahrnehmung nicht präsent sind.
Dann fehlen eben Vorbilder,
bei denen man denkt:
"Das ist cool,
das will ich auch machen."
Das fehlt ein bisschen.
Das Blasmusiksterben
ist ein Prozess,
der sich in den nächsten 10,
20 Jahren beschleunigen wird.
Dass jedes Dorf seinen Verein hat,
wird nicht mehr so sein.
* Verspielte Klänge *
Beim Klarinettenspielen
gibt es ja zwei Dinge,
die anders sind:
Erstens
muss man zuerst einen Ton erzeugen.
Bis der Ton nur kommt,
ist es schon ein Krampf.
Das Klarinettenspielen
ist eine doppelte Belastung,
da man einen Ton erzeugen muss
und man erst dann anfangen kann,
etwas damit zu machen.
Das ist der Unterschied
zu einem Tasteninstrument.
Das ist manchmal ein echter Krampf,
das muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Was es heute anscheinend gibt,
sind solche, die im Internet
eine Art Kurse anbieten,
wie man Schwyzerörgeli lernen kann.
Das scheint mir
eine gute Idee zu sein.
Vor Kurzem fragte mich jemand,
ob ich einen Kontrabasslehrer kenne.
Da meinte ich, in Zürich,
und fing an, einige aufzuzählen.
Aber eben, Zürich.
Hier oben kenne ich wirklich keinen.
Wenn jemand so etwas macht,
könnte es wirklich eine Chance sein.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Liebe Grüsse aus dem Paradies.
Der Beschluss,
mich selbstständig zu machen,
fasste ich in Australien,
wo ich vor zwei Jahren
in einem Austauschsemester war -
im Rahmen
meines Wirtschaftsingenieurstudiums.
Das war während des Lockdowns.
Da hatte ich so viel Zeit,
am Strand hin- und herzugehen.
Dort konnte ich mich mental
dazu überwinden,
alles auf die Karte
Selbstständigkeit zu setzen.
Alle Leute um mich dachten,
ich spinne, und hatten auch Angst.
"Wie willst du die Miete bezahlen?
Das geht doch nicht."
Man müsse doch Sicherheit haben.
Und ich dachte immer,
im schlimmsten Fall gehe ich pleite.
In Australien am Strand
kamen viele Ideen.
Eine Idee war: Es wäre doch cool,
wenn ich mein Handorgelwissen
weitergeben könnte.
"Stümpeli Ländler" -
herzlich willkommen zum Lernvideo.
Es sind zwei Teile,
beide Teile sind auf C-Dur.
Ich spiele den ersten Teil
einmal ganz langsam.
Zwei, drei ...
Meine Vision ist,
dass jeder, der Bock hat,
ans Tablet, Handy
oder den Laptop kann
und sich in die Community einloggt.
So hat man Zugriff
auf Hunderte von Lernvideos
und kann so Handorgel lernen.
Ich wünsche dir viel Spass
beim Lernen.
Man sieht sich beim nächsten Stück.
Für mich ist die Morgenroutine da,
um mich zu grounden, zu eichen.
Sie hilft mir, etwas Struktur
in den Tag zu bekommen.
Ich habe ja keinen Chef, der sagt,
ich müsse um 7.30 Uhr im Büro sein.
Da ich am Morgen der Natur zuhöre
und zuschaue,
gibt mir das Inspiration,
aber es gibt auch Motivation,
da man schon ein gutes Gefühl hat,
wenn man diese Eindrücke erlebt.
Das beflügelt einem bei allem,
was man am Tag macht.
Vor rund zehn Jahren war ich in
der Berufslehre als Hochbauzeichner.
Dort fand ich nicht 100 % Erfüllung.
Ich hatte immer die Vision,
morgens voller Elan aufzustehen -
egal, ob Sonntag oder Montag ist.
Diese Vision
hat sich bereits verwirklicht.
Ich kann voller Freude aufstehen,
da ich weiss,
dass ich zu 100 % an meinen Träumen
arbeiten und sie verwirklichen kann.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Ich mache mich auf den Weg
und fahre nach Zürich.
Am Hauptbahnhof treffe ich Madlaina
und zusammen gehen wir nach Brugg.
Wir haben dort Hauptprobe
für zwei Konzerte
mit den Fränzlis
und dem Orchesterverein Brugg.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Fränzlis sind für mich eine
sehr wichtige Volksmusikformation,
denn sie spielen alte Volksmusik,
aber es heisst oft,
sie würden moderne Dinge machen.
Da sieht man die Problematik:
Sie machen wirklich Musik
aus einer anderen Zeit,
aber da es nicht
die gleiche Volksmusik ist,
die sich gewisse Leute im Land
gewohnt sind,
denkt man, es sei etwas anderes.
Es funktioniert einfach
und klingt unglaublich schön.
Und sie haben eine Leidenschaft,
die man selten sieht.
Sie bringen die Musik
innerhalb der Familie auf den Punkt.
* Beschwingte Orchestermusik *
Wenn mich jemand fragt,
sage ich oft,
es sei Ländlermusik -
was nicht ganz korrekt ist.
Es ist insofern korrekt,
da wir instrumentale Musik machen.
Aber wir beziehen uns auf die Musik
noch vor der Ländlermusik -
auf Engadiner Tanzmusik
aus der zweiten Hälfte des 19. Jh.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Der Sound - wir nennen ihn manchmal
"Fränzlis-Sound":
Wenn Geige und Klarinette
die gleiche Stimme spielen,
ist es nie ...
... zu 100 % rein.
Das gibt
einen etwas jubilierenden Klang.
Den nennen wir "Fränzlis-Sound".
* Beschwingte Orchestermusik *
Als wir die Fränzlis-Besetzung
gründeten,
besannen wir uns
auf die ursprünglichen Stücke,
die wir gelernt hatten
oder die wir gehört hatten,
als wir noch klein waren.
Musik ist Tradition bei uns.
Der Grossvater hatte 55 Jahre lang
das Musikleben in Tschlin
beeinflusst.
Er war Musik- und Chordirigent.
Der Vater half dann
mit seinen Brüdern tatkräftig mit.
Sie musizierten in jungen Jahren
und hatten eine Familienkapelle.
Mit Kamera und Mikrofon gingen wir
schon 1968 ins Unterengadin
und zeigten den Zuschauern,
wie dort musiziert wurde.
* Beschwingte Musik *
(Janett)
Die alten Stücke finden wir so gut,
dass wir dachten, so etwas Gutes
könne man gar nicht machen.
Dann probiert man selber,
etwas zu machen,
das vielleicht
ein bisschen anders ist,
damit es nicht schlechter ist
als das, das es bereits gibt.
Dann kamen die Jungen dazu und
machten plötzlich auch noch etwas,
das dann nicht alt war.
So dienen die alten Stücke
als Inspiration für neue.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Das Publikum setzt sich eher
aus älteren Menschen zusammen.
Bei der Volksmusik und Klassik
wird vom Blick über den Silbersee
gesprochen -
von der Bühne aus.
Man sieht sehr viele graue Haare.
Das hat sicher mit der Musik
und der Art Musik zu tun,
aber auch damit,
dass die Senioren mehr Zeit haben,
um Konzerte zu besuchen,
und meistens genug Geld,
um Tickets zu kaufen.
Es gibt natürlich Bereiche
der Volksmusik,
in denen das Publikum
in den letzten 40 Jahren
zusammen mit den Musikanten
älter geworden ist.
Es gibt aber auch neuere Strömungen,
in denen junge Leute
junges Publikum anlocken können.
Wenn man an ein Fest
wie eine Chilbi geht
oder spezielle Volksmusikanlässe -
es gibt z.B. die Ländlerschlacht.
* Lauter Gesang
mit beschwingter Ländlermusik *
Das ist ein Riesenfestzelt,
in dem junge Musikanten spielen
und das Publikum auch sehr jung ist.
Die kommen aber aus einem anderen
Grund an ein Volksmusikanlass.
Die kommen vielleicht weniger,
um sich hinzusetzen und zuzuhören,
sondern die kommen eher wegen
des gemeinschaftlichen Erlebnisses
und um Party zu machen.
Insofern
kann man nicht pauschalisieren,
dass das Volksmusikpublikum alt ist.
Man könnte es allerdings vermuten,
wenn man die Sendungen sieht,
denn dort finden Jüngere
weniger ins Publikum.
Allerdings sind sie dann
unter den Musizierenden vertreten.
Was hilft,
damit das Publikum jünger wird, ist,
dass es immer mehr
junge Formationen gibt.
Die sind vielleicht noch nicht 18,
oder 18, 20.
Die bekennen sich auch voll
zum Brauchtum oder zur Volksmusik
und zeigen das, was dazu führt,
dass es immer mehr
jüngeres Publikum gibt,
das das hört.
Das ist das eine.
Andererseits wagen viele Junge
noch einen Schritt mehr
und integrieren eine moderne Melodie
in die Volksmusik
und machen damit ein Cross-over.
Sie spielen z.B. ein Lied aus
den Charts mit dem Schwyzerörgeli.
Das trifft den Nerv der Zeit.
Ein Cross-over könnte für Junge
ein Tor zur Volksmusik sein.
# Madlaina.
Tschau.
- Tschau.
* Rhythmische Streichmusik *
Social Media ...
Ich muss fast fragen, was das ist.
Nein ...
Ich mache fast nichts selber.
Mein Sohn Gian Andrin
lädt manchmal etwas für mich hoch.
Lustigerweise
ist es meist ein Erfolg,
denn viele kennen mich.
Aber ich selber
mache praktisch nichts.
Ich finde das Ganze nicht schlecht,
aber ich bin nicht so geschickt
und fast etwas zu bequem,
um zu versuchen, da reinzukommen.
Obwohl es vielleicht
eine Chance wäre,
damit jemanden zu erreichen,
der dann an ein Konzert kommt
und sehen will, wie es live ist.
Das wäre vielleicht schon möglich.
Beim SRF
darf ich als junge Reporterin
andere Seiten der Volksmusik
zeigen -
mit kurzen Videos,
die für Social Media geeignet sind,
lustigen Challenges
oder indem ich neue Dinge lerne.
Hoi, wir sind in Appenzell,
am vierten Jodlerfest der Saison.
Ich bin ziemlich spontan
bei meinen Beiträgen.
Ich entdecke neue Dinge,
lerne neue Instrumente
oder fordere andere Leute heraus.
Man weiss nie,
was dabei herauskommt.
Das macht es spannend
und ist lustig.
Unsere Videos
werden auf Social Media verbreitet.
Da sie dafür gedacht sind,
sind sie kurz und knackig.
Es ist etwas anderes
als z.B. eine "Potzmusig"-Sendung.
# Tüend all mini Gschpänli
scho gspane ha, so findi ...
Es gibt Teile der Volksmusik,
die verstaubt sind.
Da muss man einfach drüberwischen
und neu machen.
Oder Junge müssen es machen -
und das tun sie ja.
Ich bin Niklaus Hess.
- Ich bin Cyrill Rusch.
Ich bin Simon Rusch.
- Und ich bin Thomas Hegner.
Zusammen sind wir Hess-Rusch-Hegner.
* Lautes Johlen *
Hess-Rusch-Hegner
sind gerade die Rockstars.
Ich fühlte mich noch nie
als Rockstar.
Ich denke, wir als Hess-Rusch-Hegner
fühlen uns nicht so.
Trotzdem
ist es für uns ein Privileg,
dass wir im Moment
gerade beliebt sind.
Alle Jungen wollen die hören.
Sie sind ausverkauft.
Es ist eine lustige Entwicklung.
# Uf de Alpe obe
isch es herrlichs Läbe.
Social Media ist eines der besten
Mittel, um etwas zu verbreiten.
Darum mache ich Videos
und lade sie auf die Plattformen.
So kann ich in kurzer Zeit
sehr viele Leute erreichen.
* Örgeliversion von "Dance Monkey" *
Es ist sogar gratis.
Damit kann man Volksmusik
schon ein wenig verbreiten
und Leute erreichen, die vorher
keinen Zugang dazu hatten.
Zudem hat es mir ermöglicht,
dass ich Partner von Youtube bin
und mit den Videos Geld verdiene.
Social Media ist megawichtig -
wie bei anderen Stilrichtungen.
Volksmusik
ist auf Insta ziemlich präsent.
Man kann unendlich vielen folgen,
die das als Hauptthema haben.
Heute gehe ich
in den Jungtalentschuppen.
Das ist d a s Volksmusiklager
für junge Leute.
Ich gehe schauen,
wer die Zukunft ist.
Wie sie so drauf sind, was sie tun
und wie es ihnen gefällt.
Ich selber
konnte fünfmal teilnehmen.
Es prägte mich mega.
Das waren immer die tollsten Wochen.
Ich lernte so viel,
lernte viele Leute kennen,
hatte noch nie so viel gelacht.
Ich hoffe,
sie haben auch eine gute Zeit.
Ich würde es machen wie immer:
sehr situativ.
So, wie du bist.
Das hat immer gut funktioniert.
Hallo. Ich bin wieder
für SRF Volksmusik unterwegs
und gehe jetzt
in den Jungtalentschuppen -
ein Volksmusiklager
vom Haus der Volksmusik.
Ich gehe schauen,
wie sie ticken, was sie tun
und wie die Zukunft der Volksmusik
aussieht.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Sie üben natürlich die ganze Zeit.
Dafür sind sie ja hier.
Sie üben in Kleinformationen,
Ensembles
und in verschiedenen
anderen Formationen.
Wenn ich wieder hier bin
in dieser Lagerstimmung,
werde ich richtig emotional.
Ich durfte wirklich
eine wunderschöne Zeit erleben.
Und man merkt,
dass es denen heute genauso geht.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
(Senn) Manchmal wäre ich gerne
wieder 20 Jahre jünger
und würde gerne
in einen Jungtalentschuppen gehen.
Dort hat man einfach
die besten Lehrer
und einen Teil
der besten Jugendlichen,
die Musik machen, sich austauschen
lernen, zusammen zu improvisieren,
und Stubeten machen.
* Sanfte Hackbrettmusik *
Ich mache mir überhaupt keine Sorgen
um die Volksmusik.
Man sieht auch auf Social Media,
wie viele coole Leute das machen.
Es ist eine megafrische Szene.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Als ich in das Lager ging,
suchten sie noch Leute.
Jetzt muss man sich bewerben
und bibbern,
da so viele Leute hingehen wollen.
Das ist ein cooles Zeichen.
* Jauchzer *
# Es gibt jetzt feine Pizza.
- # Ia-ia-ho.
# Es sind die guten Köche, ia-ia-ho.
# Wir bringen euch das gute Essen.
- # Ia-ia-ho.
# Sie bringen uns das gute Essen,
ia-ia-ho.
Von 1-10: Wie fest
freutest du dich aufs Lager?
Das ist die schönste Woche
des Jahres.
Ich freue mich wirklich jedes Jahr.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Ich denke, die Szene wird
durch die jungen Leute vielfältiger.
Die haben Lust auf mehr
und wollen nicht immer
das Gleiche hören oder machen.
Darum suchen sie neue Dinge.
Viele entdecken auch Volksmusik,
haben aber noch ein anderes Leben.
Sie sind nicht nur auf dem Bauernhof
und hören nur diese Musik,
sondern sie gehen auch an Festivals
oder Rockkonzerte.
So sehen sie, dass beides cool ist
und man es kombinieren kann.
Das ist bereichernd.
Es geht auch mir so,
ich bin in der Volksmusik,
habe aber auch eine andere Seite.
Darum passt es,
wenn ich diesen Job mache.
Ich kann Leuten in der Volksmusik
eine modernere Seite zeigen,
und Leuten, die nicht dabei sind,
dass Volksmusik auch cool ist.
Sie ist vielfältig.
Der Tag war traumhaft -
noch besser als gedacht.
Es machte mega Spass.
Jetzt ist gerade Stubete.
Das ist im Lager jeden Abend so.
Da spielen verschiedene Formationen
ganz spontan.
Die meisten tanzen dazu.
Es wird gejasst.
So, wie eine Stubete halt ist.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Ich wünsche mir
für die Zukunft der Volksmusik,
dass genau das passiert,
was gerade angestrebt wird:
dass die alten Traditionen bleiben,
sie sich aber weiterentwickeln,
damit viele Leute
Freude daran haben.
Dass man die Wurzeln nicht vergisst.
Dass die ganz alten Jodel,
Jutze, Schottisch usw.
erhalten bleiben,
denn das ist sehr wertvoll.
Dass viele Leute
Freude daran haben können.
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Es ist gut, wie es ist.
Es soll so weitergehen.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Ich wünsche mir für die Volksmusik,
dass sie erhalten bleibt,
lebendig bleibt
und die Leute sie auch schätzen.
Manchmal wünsche ich mir auch,
dass die Bevölkerung der Schweiz
mehr Wertschätzung
gegenüber dieser Musik zeigt.
Dass es nichts Hinterwäldlerisches
ist, sondern etwas unseres Landes.
Das ist unsere Kultur.
Ich wünsche mir, dass die Leute
in die Emotionen eintauchen
und das Werten und Etikettieren
zweitrangig wird.
Dass die Schubladen
grösser gebaut werden,
damit auch die schmalen Platz haben.
Ich wünsche der Szene einfach,
dass diese Vielfalt bleibt.
Verschiedene Instrumente,
Harmonien, die sich entwickeln,
Rhythmen, die sich weiterentwickeln.
Was kommt,
ist eigentlich megaspannend.
Ich freue mich auf alles,
was noch auf uns einklingen wird.
Dass man sich erinnert,
dass es Gebrauchsmusik ist,
und man sie eben
auch ein bisschen wild hält.
Ich würde mir wünschen,
dass es immer
im Bewusstsein der Menschen bleibt,
und dass v.a. Junge,
die gar keinen Zugang dazu haben,
es nicht kennen
und noch nie gehört haben,
etwas Neues entdecken können.
Man muss versuchen, coole Anlässe
für die Jungen zu machen.
Wenn es viele Junge gibt,
kommen auch Junge.
Jetzt kommen wirklich
schon wieder Junge nach,
die ein ernsthaftes Interesse
und eine Leidenschaft
für die Ländlermusik haben.
Ich wünsche mir,
dass sie am Ball bleiben
und auch sie zur Förderung der Szene
beitragen können.
Ich wünsche mir, dass die Jungen
diese Musik im Herzen tragen
und mit dem Herzen
an die Leute weitervermitteln.
Für die Zukunft der Volksmusik
wünsche ich mir,
dass die guten Musiker,
die sich Mühe geben,
saubere, gute Musik zu machen
oder sauber und gut zu singen,
nicht weniger Erfolg haben
als diejenigen,
die sich einfach gut verkaufen.
Für die Zukunft wünsche ich der
Schweizer Volksmusik nur das Beste.
Gesund bleiben ...
... und zahlreiche Kinder.
Dass es weitergeht -
und das wird es auch.
Mehr braucht es gar nicht.
Ja.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023